Can you hear us?
Are we up and cracking?
We had sound for a second there.
Oh,
we did have some.
It just didn't show it in the window.
We have sound now.
Just come on and jump over to the
pitches.
Chuck over there.
Try.
They'll tell you right up immediately.
Get the chat is faggots and they're all
living in now.
It's chance gay.
I heard you for two seconds just now.
Yes.
Okay.
It's working eggs and so Chicago out of
this.
Right.
Otherwise it won't work.
All right.
I'll tell the twitter people last time.
This is week though this thing because
it already adds.
Hey,
Joe Rogan.
Si.
Hi.
Welcome to the Joe Rogan podcast.
Where's that?
Tom and I figured out the technical
difficulties.
I'm Brian Tom Zass and we've got to get
it out.
So we got our Tomahawk pipe that we're
going to over the last week.
You said a peace pipe.
What is a peace pipe?
Fucking battle.
A war.
Your choice bitch firepower.
I don't think it's probably the best
pipe.
It looks like a piece of shit.
It's already clogged.
Clogged.
No,
it looks cool though,
but we got a real one right here.
So what I fuck around bitches and since
all three of us are legal,
this were illegally medicating here.
See what you're looking at is three sick
people.
Are you get headaches is I get
headaches,
sleeplessness,
and headaches from Mr [inaudible],
headaches,
sleeplessness,
and I said I had surgery the year
before.
That's all true.
I get really bad anxiety,
but the rest of the sentence is when I
smoke weed.
All right.
We're up and cracking people.
You keep your partner bag like the
oldest that was given to me.
I was like,
there's no other reason.
So,
uh,
I should kill his game music and sound
really gay.
It's just not really good.
Created by and for homosexuals.
Why does it fit with the vibe we're
trying to follow here?
You guys are liars and it's completely
cool.
Um,
what do we lie about Fela?
Oh,
about our prescriptions.
It helps me sleep one wrong.
Gives me anxiety that I had.
And it did.
It is legal,
right?
If you had to guess,
either everyone's watching you or no
one's locked in you,
what would you say?
Everybody feels like everybody's
watching me.
[inaudible] you're paranoid.
Yeah.
He gets paranoid when he smokes weed,
but that's what I told the doctor and he
still gave it to me.
Is Everybody in here?
Here we go.
Oh,
you need to unpack that.
This one?
Yeah.
This one's fucked us up.
I got some weak ass wack ass DSL
Internet,
but I'm a new internet installed.
I just have to install a new router and
then from there we'll be able to upload
videos.
We'll be able to.
I'm going to change this background and
bring a couch in here and get rid of
this desk and put a new desk in and so I
only have one desk.
I got this big ass long desolate rooms
all clogged up.
Someone put a couch in here.
Have a little table right there.
We have the microphone set up there so
we can lounge and do this properly.
Ladies and gentlemen,
check this shit out.
I just got an.
This is awful.
Imagine having to deal with this.
My mom has a windows xp computer that's
like seven years old and she only has 56
k Internet available at her house.
Really trying to help her fix a computer
from a virus and she could only connect
at 56,000
people in viruses.
Me Shoot.computer.
There's no way you're gonna fix it,
but can you imagine only getting 56 gay?
No,
I can't.
I did for a long time.
Shit.
I started out with 14 four.
I started out with the AOL on an old ass
mack,
one of those tan ones,
the beige ones,
and it had a 14 for Bard Internet
connection.
Do you remember how brutal that Shit
was?
Remember when three d came out,
motherfucker.
Everybody got 56 can.
I was like,
man,
I can't believe it.
That's like five times as fast.
I remember paying like $120 for 56 k
modem back in the day and that was like
so much money.
Just like,
oh,
you gotta tell people online who wants
to use it on gun?
Hey,
you couldn't use the goddamn phone.
That's craziness man.
Well,
now that's a t and t uverse thing.
If the phone goes,
if the Internet goes down,
everything's down.
If the computer,
if the,
the,
uh,
the tvs down,
then you're falling down fire arrows to.
Everything's done.
How would you match them?
You've got to go by memory.
How boys was telling you masturbating,
but memory.
Shower the whole time.
Wow.
Look at you.
You sexy.
Cavemen had to draw what they wanted to
masturbate to first.
Like Kate mentioned,
raped and fucked.
I don't think they bothered masturbate.
Masturbation is a byproduct of
civilization.
If we were in civilized will be raped
and like a motherfucker,
it'd be no.
There'd be no masturbating.
You just find someone there.
Be No gay.
Yeah.
Rape her brother and she had been raped
and everybody.
Yeah,
there would be no masturbation if there
was caveman right now.
I don't know.
I think there's a lot more work because
there was no other way that we're going
to have good old people.
Old People just get raped all day.
Everybody be waiting in line to rape the
next old person when you didn't have a
language and couldn't say,
Hey,
fucking stop and you couldn't fight
someone off.
Back in those days it was just ready to
reason with people and say,
listen,
when you are raping me,
you're hurting me.
I know it feels good temporarily,
but there's other solutions.
You can't talk someone out of rape when
there's no language.
They just tack your ass.
Right?
I mean that's logic,
right?
Do you think a girl that's in a coma is
just like a robot fucked off?
No,
she didn't do anything.
No.
That's rude,
man.
That's not a doll.
It's a person.
She's never going to come out to come
and go,
so.
But she's still a human being issue.
I don't know.
Here's the thing about promise.
Have you ever seen like one of those
interviews where someone was in a coma
for like seven years and then for
whatever reason I just woke up and he
said he was awake the whole time.
Would that be awful?
So fuck that man.
Get Web casts tips from Anthony Kumina.
That's a very good idea.
Next time I go on,
oh,
ONA would definitely gonna do that.
We're going to find out what it is.
A great one from us is a two pound.
His is interesting.
Once you get your Internet,
that's all I'm waiting for.
I just bring my laptop over here and
this shit will be changed.
Ryan's connect go off.
I've been just waiting for the Internet
upgrade.
I think this is a good thing to commit
to.
This is the 2010 commitment.
We're going to do this every week so
easy.
Just hop on and fuck around and
everybody enjoys it.
Does Anthony,
does anthony have guests?
He's got everything,
man.
He's got guests.
He's got these cameras that are like
real,
like studio quality cameras.
He's got real like radio station
microphones.
Get everything.
He's got a background green screen so he
changes.
It can make it look too.
That's what we need.
This back wall needs to be a fucking
green screen behind that roller coaster
effect.
How hard would that be?
That wouldn't be hard,
right?
Buy.
I have a sheet.
I can bring a street over there.
That's going to happen right there.
The weld cables installed,
I just need to change the router.
Okay.
Take a picture of this and grades grade
the exact same background behind us.
Oh,
that'd be so dope.
You know,
be cool.
If it is.
If we added like two mirrors looking
into each other where they look
infinitely.
If you see that video I posted today on
your message board under.
I wish so.
I can't wait to my cell phone.
Does this?
No,
there's,
there's a video on Joe's message board.
It's under the topic on the called.
I can't wait till my cell phone does
this and it's this company that does a
special effects so that you can pretty
much and it shows all their samples and
it's just like backgrounds of buildings
that you would never think was a green
screen and it just shows you like the
scenes first and then it shows how.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Could you imagine if you could do that
with your phone?
If you could like put your phone down
and change.
We're looking at,
you know that's what's going to happen
eventually when they figured out how to
broadcast images and make them look real
like it's right in front of you,
like not just on a screen but an actual
hologram that looks real right in front
of you.
God Damn.
Could you imagine when your tv becomes
something that you just place in the
middle of your living room?
You put it down on the image just cause
man,
like old school Princess Leia type shit.
But like you can't tell the difference
though.
You know what I mean?
Calling tents.
Would that be.
It will start off like vhs quality where
you're like,
I could kinda tell the different salts.
Staticky and television was the big
thing.
If the three d glasses though,
fuck has one where you don't have to.
Well I didn't see them in three d I saw
in regular and even in regular.
Holy fucking shit.
That movie's good.
It's not like a good movie,
like really great writing and you can't
believe they were there.
You see everything coming a mile away
and you don't care.
I'll probably,
I just feel like no,
you're not going to say it's all right.
If you get super baked,
you're going to love the fuck out of
that movie.
It's so you say,
you know,
either it has to listen to this story
though.
You're going to see the storyline,
but it's not going make that up,
but it's not for that.
It's a comic book,
man.
It's bullshit.
It's just entertainment.
Just pretend like you're 15 again and
you're just watching some.
Oh my God.
Is there good action.
Jesus fucking Christ,
Bro.
I didn't want to tell you about it
because I don't want to ruin it.
I don't.
I don't wanna.
I don't wanna be the,
the,
my shit like that.
Or just pocket spy movie.
This thing is off the charts and I
didn't even see it in three d apparently
in three d.
it's insane.
Like Black said that three days a month
because he was movies more than anybody,
but I'm asking.
Not Necessary,
but I've asked her to lead.
He's probably seen 10 times already
received a few times.
Mike Black,
if you've talked to him on a Tuesday as
they want to see a movie,
he's already seen everything.
Jesus every week,
he just goes every week.
He's always gets that midnight.
Showing movies when they're good,
like Avatar was a great experience.
There's something,
I believe there's something about seeing
a movie in front of a bunch of people
too.
It's a totally different experience
watching a movie by yourself,
you know,
when is it shitty movie.
Then you're just watching a movie shitty
movie with a bunch of people and it's
succeed.
We also help with three m.
We still walked fucking terrible.
That movie was so.
There's people that love couldn't know,
but I think they're hell boy fans.
They're fans.
The comic book first
and that's what we fucked up on.
We were.
We didn't know what was going on.
I couldn't get high enough to.
What's the responsibility of the movie
to make you understand even if you're
not a fan.
Yes,
but that's what happens in those big,
like big story.
Things like Harry Potter.
I saw the last Harry Potter,
which fuck it was death.
I couldn't.
I couldn't wait for it to be over.
It was like being in jail.
It was terrible.
It was.
It wasn't even remotely entertaining.
There was nothing entertaining about
Harry Potter.
It was pretty good.
The first one was really,
really good.
Where their head broom,
broomball thing.
Yeah.
That was fucking dope.
I don't agree.
Monster.
One of the second ones.
I think a second one was when the dragon
was coming after him.
Was that the second one?
I think that was.
You know,
I think that was the third one.
The third one with the tree.
That dragon scene was worth the whole
movie and may like,
like everybody talks about how the hulk
shocks that have totally sucked,
but when he's fucking shit up man,
and you're worth it.
That was,
I want a new marvel movies.
I've been pretty good.
The iron man.
It's fucking insane.
The new one looks even crazier and
that's going to be a good story.
Along with the action.
I could watch Wolverine Man.
The last little was stupid.
I'm sure the action is just as good as
some other stuff,
but it's like it was too predictable.
Like there's like there's the scene
where the gasolines running away from
the car and he's walking away and he
likes to,
gasoline in the car,
blows up behind.
How many fucking times can you see that
one?
That fucking scene is
and they don't even look into exactly
what
was.
It was just so stupid.
So like I'm a bad ass,
you know,
that you got to come up with a new way
to be the new bad ass isn't like some
guys like snarling and the new bad ass
is the guy like fate or it doesn't say
shit.
I would do it.
I'm trying to be cool.
I like to start to walk away,
but then I started to assume what's
going to happen.
So I started on like,
yeah,
and I'm like,
wait,
what's happening?
And then we'll close for strap.
No stupid.
How can you assume it's not going to hit
you?
It's going to blow up back there.
It's going to come flying off trail so
long and around a building.
Yeah.
I would run like a phil pay above the
line.
It still want to say,
yeah,
pay a bundle.
I said,
look,
I'm pretty sure in the movies,
movies never.
You can talk some sensitive and he'd be
like,
Yup,
Yup.
That'd be a great movie.
Have a guy like a cigarette,
put it out and then just out and yeah,
that would be crazy.
Do you guys about this before?
Wouldn't it be awesome to have a job to
watch moving and just your whole job,
which is going all right.
I totally went into,
I want to keep my keys on the dashboard
while I'm at Mcdonald's or something
like,
you know,
just because so many movies you're into
and then you're like,
oh,
what's so it seems like could be cute.
Yes.
Professional Hollywood independent.
You should start an agency.
So they have that thing where they,
where people go to see TV shows and
they.
It's
probably,
they probably have that already and it's
like the gaffer,
but we just never knew what the gaffer
was.
One person.
You're probably bugging a whole bunch of
people.
Totally.
And people just deal with it.
You know?
It's like girls that won't tell you that
your breath stinks,
but the more you have to do that,
the more takes you out of the movie.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
Well,
there's some scenes like that.
An Avatar,
definitely.
There's a couple of scenes that you
didn't have to do.
It was just.
There was a few cliches that were like
so extreme.
It was almost like it wasn't even a
movie and was just like,
this is how how clunky some of the
acting was.
Even sigourney weaver was so clunky,
it wasn't like it was a movie.
It was like,
you know how you go to universal studios
and you go on a ride and before the
play,
that little video,
it was like that back in,
but you're not fully back in.
You've got to come out and cliches.
We're just so off the charts so that
Zombie land that it was pretty good,
but then the chicks that I learned at
the end,
it's almost like you had me at hello and
all of a sudden I'm like,
oh,
I'm watching a movie.
Isn't that what that whole movie was
kind of about cheesy humor mixed with
zombies and this is what I want to know.
Is There A.
is there a single human being,
the saw the ads for that fucking.
Let me tell you about the morgans,
the,
you know the,
the movie with Sarah Jessica Parker and
you got the new one that's out now.
Something about the morgans.
These.
You're a fucking single Schulman who saw
that?
That ad went fuck.
Yeah,
there had to be sure this huge barker
pounds.
Yeah,
but even a huge Sarah Jessica Parker fan
doesn't give a fuck about hugh grant.
Somebody who was coked out of their mind
when agreement,
that fucking movie.
I think we got a winner here.
We've got a huge grant and we got Sarah
Jessica Parker and then someone pulls.
The Guy said,
yeah,
but it's 2010.
It must suck to if you're a
screenwriter.
I'm thinking about Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie is like,
awesome.
It's like I'm in the studio sometimes
like,
Hey,
instead of that we're going with these
guys want to keep it a little low
budget.
Why would you?
Well,
they're committed.
They have two projects going right now.
It will be at least a year and a half.
This is so good.
We don't need stars.
We don't need,
but we don't need talent.
We want a god that got arrested for
getting blown by black hookers.
Remember the ass gusting one ruined his
career.
Sort of,
but not really.
Right.
He kind of came back,
you know,
you could get,
you could get busted doing something
like that if you're an actor and for
some reason it's okay.
Projects in the works already.
They don't want to eat them on credit.
Didn't have anything in the works.
Yeah.
If you've got projects in the works well
he never had anything in the world and
it's a weird fuck.
Like Mel Gibson had like three things.
Comments.
Were they going to do?
Not Show them?
Let's talk shit about Kramer.
Did you?
Uh,
did you ever have to deal with him,
the Jews?
Did you ever have to deal with him at
the college store?
Yeah,
I saw him not in a bad way.
I saw him,
um,
when he got there and I was like,
oh,
cool,
grab her sphere.
You know,
it wasn't really there.
It wasn't until,
um,
but then it's almost stage like,
oh,
this isn't good.
People stopped.
People stopped being weirded out by.
It was like that night before it
happened to Kramer's here,
he's fucking like on crack or something
with some crazy chick and they're in
like an hour later,
that all happens.
Either Brent,
Ernst or Mazda was,
he told us he came back from the laugh
factory and told us he was like,
Brent,
what does it bring it up?
Yeah,
that's what I was saying.
Your brand.
No,
I said Brent,
Brent.
Anyway,
he came over and just told the to Kramer
what fucking crazy started yelling
nigger people.
We were like,
what?
We thought it was like another.
What else thinks the world of comedy.
You always hear about some shit.
Like,
hey,
we heard what happened.
Tom Perez pulled his cock out and slap
some lady in the face of that.
Like,
shut the fuck up man.
Mad.
It's getting crazy.
That's normal dress.
Cool.
I wish I would've been there.
I left like an hour.
Yeah,
you'd be pissed off.
One of the things about the old school
comedy stores,
you never wanted to go home because you
never knew what the fuck was going on.
I made the mistake of thinking of shows
over where a guy who was minding out big
broken up with by a porn star,
she started fondling and touching her
boyfriend who was there and he was like,
please pick her up on a please take me
back.
I can change.
And they got on stage.
I thought it was done.
I was like,
ah.
That was a great night,
and I left later.
The porn star.
It was fucking her boyfriend right to
the side of the stage while everybody
was watching.
Yeah.
Well,
what barriers have gone home?
It just seemed like it was all wrapped
up.
That shit will happen all the time to
come to them ever known.
You're going to see their line of seen
everything on a penis and the comedy
store.
It seems like everyone was just showing
you your Dick Comics like that.
So it's so funny because it's funny.
It's hilarious.
Let's stick with your flacid gross penis
chick's name that was onstage where Joey
was in the back of the room at the
original one,
came out and kept pulling his balls out
and she thought she was calling the
police.
She was terrible.
She was a terrible convenient.
Chrissy,
I forget what her name.
No,
no,
no.
Anyway,
whatever the chick's name was.
She.
She's on stage and she's one of those
lifers that had been doing comedy like
20 plus years,
but it never made a living out of it,
which was the comedy store,
Kinda like kept those people around
where it's like those people like the
really,
really crazy people that are not really
in the world of comedy,
but they're sort of in the world
economy.
They don't get up at the Improv,
they don't get.
But at the store those people would get
actually get on,
really want to stage time and they want
to run through them and panic when you
see them on the line because you thought
they would clear the room and they
would.
They will usually will clear that
fucking room anytime the time.
Yeah,
and so anyways,
so she's on stage and every time she
goes near bucks,
like we all see interactive million
times.
Julie Diaz is behind her.
The way the original room worked,
you could actually sneak up on somebody
while they're on stage.
Open up the Kurt and gravel curtain
right there.
Fully stand back.
They're told plenty of road you got like
this much room,
so jelly goes back there,
take solace fucking clothes off and
every time she is a punchline,
he pulls open the curtain and shots
shaking his balls and his big giant
grapefruit balls or slapping around and
then he would close it back up and she
didn't see shit.
She thought she was slated that you guys
liked that one.
She was all jolly and happy.
Like all of a sudden she figured comedy
out like yes,
my hard work has come to fruition.
When that happens through the whole back
row fills it with comedian,
comedian on stage was like,
oh cool.
The comments and watching me,
they whatever.
Nope.
We've seen so much crazy shit at that
place that the comedy store,
the old school hang outs with the best
part about the comedy store,
the audiences were some of the worst
ever,
which is one of the reasons why you
develop like,
like,
like people say like,
Oh,
you know,
you're always dealing with hecklers.
Like uh,
you know what,
what does that leg is that.
Does that freak you out?
Like when you start out at the comedy
store,
Dude,
you have to deal with hecklers.
Know it's not every time,
but it's like 105.
The only time they get rid of the guys
when violence is about the habit,
it gets to the point of violence.
Like people are standing up screaming at
people and the audience members to come
to the booth and they're complaining
about a different audience.
Yeah.
You need like people ready to stab
people for them to do anything.
Otherwise they wouldn't do shit.
So you develop that style,
this style that you like.
You have.
And I have and Joey has where you could
just flip around.
You don't say you're,
you're at from beginning to end.
Like some people,
especially like a lot of guys who start
out in clubs in New York,
you get really short sets,
you know,
you don't get to fuck around on stage
for a half an hour or an hour and then
you don't get like those,
those nice long sets and when you get
those nice long sets then you could put
material where you want it and fuck
around and be loose and it's got a
showcase.
It's like your seven minutes just to get
ready.
Like Hey,
what's up everyone?
And you don't have time at all.
If you go go,
go,
go and get off.
Like isn't it frustrated too?
And you have to do a TV show and you
have to do like seven minutes.
You're like shut.
Not at times a bit and a half and you
don't know how to set it up.
It's like,
yeah,
this is a good bit,
but it's really good after talking for
10 minutes and you know my personality,
you know where I'm coming from there.
It's a different type of.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's totally to seven minutes.
That's only pretty much are better at
that.
More realized their potential than
someone who is reduced along stuff that
has to cut it down.
Yeah.
You get used to what you can get away
with because you can't really dig a hole
and you really know your pixel if you
dig a hole in seven minutes.
So like there's.
There's bits that I have where I know
like,
like the baby blow job,
but that's possible whole time that
someone could fall in the open and close
with that fucking thing.
People would be like,
what?
No,
you can't talk about this yet.
I don't know how you think,
but if they know how you think they know
all this guy's just being silly.
He's just fucking around.
He's a really nice guy and he realizes
this is all in fun.
We're just having a good time up here.
Then people will accept craziness if
they know it's all bullshit,
but if they don't know you,
he can't just go on stage and you might
have this killer,
brilliant bit,
but you'll.
You'll do the first opening line of it
and they'll just start eating it right
away.
Like fuck,
it's like,
wow,
I haven't got a whole.
I have a format whole,
I have to fill this.
I have just dropped a bit right now.
It's fuck it,
do something else real.
I mean real comedy is in front of an
audience in comedy,
not comedy on television.
Even comedy.
Like when I felt like I did my comedy
special,
like I'm happy that people can get ahold
of it,
but it's really just an ad to get them
to come see us.
The real thing.
Yeah.
It's.
I mean it's nice.
It's got the material down and you know,
you can see it without having to drive
across the country to where people are
like,
well,
what's the difference?
I can still see the jokes.
That's exactly what they saw because
send me what you miss is the connection
you make with an audience and you
weren't in that audience.
Feel that,
feel and hear the same things you've
heard and that's a huge point right
there.
The connection,
because it isn't just the jokes that are
really.
It's not,
it's.
You can't discount it.
It's a real.
There's a real thing that's happening
with you in the audience.
It's very strange.
It's like,
um,
like almost like a lego psychic
connection,
you know,
like there's moments where they know
exactly what you're thinking and you can
just pause and consider something and
they'll start laughing because they know
by,
based on having gone there,
they're going there with you,
with other comics,
by watching them on TV.
But I do the same thing.
I just heard not too.
It still looks right.
It looks like somebody just sent me
right
tape of some guy check out this guy and
he's really funny and I was like
watching the clip,
but I'm like,
no,
no.
Laurie Martin.
Remember Her New York.
I think January first or second she was
doing a show that somebody threw a role
at her read role.
It was just a heckler video and I was
watching Legos.
It's pretty good.
If I was there,
you know,
you don't know what's going to happen.
You're caught up in the moment.
She knows that about the crowd.
That's how she was just a certain way.
People love that.
The when,
when moments just happen.
When you're in the middle of a show,
no standup comedy really is sort of like
a massive gnosis.
It's like some weird mass connection
with people and what you're doing with
like a video is you're just hoping that
someone will sort of get a little bit of
that connection.
You know,
you'll get like a little,
like a little vibration of it,
a little,
just like a faint memory of that
connection.
You get the material and understand good
writing,
all that stuff,
but there's a moment that happens when
you're onstage and you're killing.
You know that moment where it's just
writing sort of feeling,
man,
I don't think too many people understand
that.
You know what people talk about?
Legos is commonly scary.
It's not scary.
People want to have a good time.
You just got to do what you're supposed
to do.
Do putting the work right a lot,
perform a lot,
do it with the right state of mind.
Do it the right intentions.
Do it all for fun.
As long as you work your.
If you're intelligent and you've been
doing it,
you know how to do it.
Just fucking do it.
Man
No kind of hurt is called scared.
Jonathan got sick,
was on stage once,
I don't know,
like 11th or whatever
it was and he was just killing right
from the start.
It's fucking destroy me
about 10 or 12 minutes go,
I have any hiccups because he realized
this might be the best out of all time.
And then he's like the last like three
minutes,
like a b plus a minus.
And was like,
oh,
but it was like,
oh my God,
I'm doing so well.
He felt responsible for the rest of the
set and I was like,
done that.
Have you ever.
You talked yourself out of killing.
Yeah,
really good.
Start eating it.
I remember there was a set that I had
when I first started doing comedy with a
for first five minutes I've fucking
crushed and then I have 10 minutes set
and then I dropped a glass.
I just fumbled,
drop the glass and didn't even know.
Dressing,
not worried about killing.
Yeah.
And then the next five minutes I just
ain't shit I fucking shit man.
It was like I went through last thing
and wow,
this guy's really funny.
What a great choice.
We picked the common show.
This is awesome because it was like,
like
in some weird place in the middle of
Rhode Island.
It wasn't even a comedy club.
It was like one of these little,
a little comedy gigs that you would get
where you know,
you drop in and do a guest spot.
Like before you were actually getting
paid.
You know?
It took me like a year before I ever got
any paid sets,
but before that year there was always
guys that had like this little bar rooms
and you can go up and do 10 minutes.
Like in Boston.
They developed a whole network of those.
There were shows everywhere.
They had comedy night all over the
place.
When I was doing comedy,
they had three comedy clubs on one
block.
Warrington St,
three on one block and a fourth one open
upstairs.
They were all packed.
It was crazy.
And then you had another one that was
only a block away.
There was a little dicto already place
and then you had another one stitches
that was only a couple miles away and
then on route one you had two huge ones.
You had the quaaludes and you had
giggles.
These are like full time clubs.
Like giggles wasn't collins.
I am maybe.
I think it was just a weekend or two,
but the other ones were seven day a
week.
Clubs.
How many people in Boston don't know?
There's a few million,
but it was crazy,
man.
There was stitches,
there was duck soup,
which was later.
Later became the Improv and then there
was,
of course nick's comedy stop.
There were so many fucking clubs.
It was the most incredible place.
I was so lucky.
Just a total streak of luck that I was
in Boston in 1988 when I wanted to do
comedy because that was like,
that was a mess and it was a mecca for
the coal country.
For whatever reason.
That one place developed all these
comics mean lack of Denis leary.
What's his face?
Steven,
right?
Uh,
and then guys,
you've never heard of Jay Leno,
of course.
Nick Depaulo.
Anthony Clark,
anything car back then was a murderer.
Do Jokes?
Yeah,
he,
I think he got a television show and
things started happening for him and I
just think a lot of stuff didn't fall
into place,
but when I was starting out back in
Boston are,
you should fear of moved away from the
camera so my grandmother doesn't say,
oh,
that's great.
I'm taking some questions.
That nosy bitch.
She's still watching.
Use Dreams.
Start taking some questions.
So you got so many people asking me
shit,
man.
Shit happens.
No,
no,
no.
How this shit works.
Okay.
When you're on the radio show,
you never have somebody telling you to
take some calls when they want to.
Not when there's a break.
When there's a break.
That was a break in the conversation.
What's wrong with you?
What are the.
What are,
what are some questions?
You get reception here today.
TNC.
It's fucking good up here for rise.
Rise.
Rise is terrible up here but a and is
the bomb diggity but Rosen's better
everywhere else but.
And I'm going to get something hooked up
where you can have a rise in,
in your house,
through the Internet.
You have like a little internet thing.
And it's like,
why cloud for your house where you live
doesn't have good internet.
Sure.
It's actually.
What it does is it uses your wildfire
and it rebroadcast.
Hey,
this ain't radio so radio,
but I mean a precedent has been set,
sir.
I would try to,
um,
we're doing it like radio,
this guy to bias holt.
He's saying red band hit him already.
Listened to fellow.
You got a lot of pent up inside question
answered.
We're friends.
It's actually to give it to them.
We're friends here.
There's no,
no one's hitting anybody.
Got Down to settle the fuck down.
Do,
do,
do
so many angry people that,
that,
that hang out in the UFC community.
Well,
it's not just the UFC community is in
the world then there's a lot of angry
motherfuckers up,
but I've noticed in this 40 5:00
AM,
yeah,
the economies in the shitter.
We're in two fucking wars.
That makes zero sense.
There's a lot of angry fucking people
out there,
man.
There's a lot of UFC people that have
noticed.
I've come onto your message board lately
that has kind of taken over the crowd
and they're either school they give.
A lot of them are cool,
so a lot of there are so many dumb asses
and fucking morons and fighter guys.
True,
but the beauty of that message board is
the retard room.
That's the beautiful thing.
If you about this killer message board
on Joe Rogan Dot net,
it's forums dot Joe Rogan.net,
and these forums we have it set up so
people are just generally instructed to
be cool with each other.
Don't be retarded.
Post interesting shared talk about
things and occasionally someone will
fucking blow up.
We'll get retarded,
get stupid.
They get angry,
they get aggro,
they start fights and so then we send
them to the retard room and we have a
special room that's just for everyone in
it has been deemed a retard.
I mean,
you're not all retarded.
I'm not somebody you'd probably just
young and some of you had a tough life
and you're crazy.
I don't hate you,
I just don't want you fucking up the
conversations and people fuck up the
conversations for more than,
you know,
a certain couple of two or three times
we sent him to this retard room.
It's the greatest invention ever.
I don't know whose it was.
Whose idea was it?
I forget.
Crescent wrench was the guy who came up
with the idea where everybody should
have to post porn.
That was his idea,
which was cool.
Yeah,
that was.
You got too far because it wasn't about.
It wasn't about saying a cool woman was.
It became like the original better point
asshole.
It came like a website where you could
just get porn.
You wouldn't have to go anywhere else,
but my website to get porn.
It was videos and,
and now with those fucking those you
porns movies.
Big giant ass fucking pictures.
Yeah.
They're huge.
Twice categories and they look good.
You know,
it's funny.
It's awesome.
The people that were in those addicted
to porn,
it had the best porn photos were the
most popular people.
So actually we,
we're,
we're friends with the most creepy
friends and people that are seven
gigabytes fairly legal
go to strip clubs when the girls
performing with magazines for it aside.
I met Gina Lynn.
She's really pretty.
She's very nice.
That's cool.
It's actually really cool.
She's a nice person.
She's not doing porn very much longer.
They liked them because they want them
out.
You can do better than this.
I just want you to know some students
are just into it.
Bella said she's done with porn.
Wow.
Acting on them.
What is she going to do now?
Just produce.
Wow.
She's going to become a pimp.
No,
she's tired of baseball.
Bats up the pooper.
I don't think she was tired.
You get tired of that.
Continue with the out of nowhere.
It's just like,
oh,
here,
here's me.
Here's my asshole.
And you're like,
oh,
it really is like that too.
She sends you nsfw not safe for work.
I think even a bigger warning then loads
dripping out of your gaping asshole.
That's not just not.
That's not safe for life.
That's ridiculous.
You're showing me.
You show them the whole world.
You're like white to the butthole,
like not mysterious lips and suck on
fingers and taunting you with laundry
wide open pod hall with sperms for
flowers,
a pitch for those deep.
She goes deep.
She takes it to another level.
She does.
She set the bar like a motherfucker.
I've never seen anybody have a baseball
bat up their ass like that.
It's a loss of the community.
It's a huge loss.
Like Jordan retiring the first time.
It is.
Who's the dirtiest girl in pour now?
Sasha grey.
Now that she's gone
third year,
supposedly really dirty.
It's just a good marketer and dirtier
than the rest of them.
She looks pretty dirty.
What happened?
Brian?
Brian,
John Candy thing bouncing on this.
You don't know what the fuck you're
doing.
This is a story behind this thing behind
us and I'm,
I'm going to put something up
in front of a bunch of pot on the
ground.
Yep.
This side,
Doug,
Stan hope and I were a hosted.
The man show.
There was a segment called make me hard
and the segment,
uh,
we had like boxes attached to dudes
dicks.
And like we'd show them things like a,
like a midget eating a banana and we
would decide,
oh,
he's getting a hard on during the day.
It was really stupid,
but the whole reason for the bit what so
that we can use this training and it's
in the bit.
We had this tranny and she was really
hot.
I mean she's a fucking super hot.
Like my friend Eddie saw her in a car
once and he was Dan at pitches.
Oh look at her.
And I go,
that's a tranny.
And he goes,
no fucking white.
Oh yeah,
we used around on the man show.
So I'm like,
Hey,
what's up?
How you doing?
So anyway,
we've got this guy with the box on.
So the idea is that we show them all
this stuff that's not not sexy like guys
playing with her nipples,
big fat guys.
And the light would go off,
you know,
a midgets eating a banana there.
Light would go off.
And then we had this super hot chick and
she's rubbing on him and she's touched
him and nothing.
Nothing's happened.
Is Light is not going up.
And she pulls her tits out,
they'll fuck it,
audience is going crazy and he's sucking
whip cream,
offered tits,
and then she pulls her cock out and her
composition wrinkled,
shriveled up little poison dick because
it's a real dick.
Like she used to be a man,
but she's been injecting herself with so
many female hormones that her dick is
like,
like addicted.
It's been poisoned.
It was like a monkey that got shot with
a poison dart,
which you would imagine his dick would
look like.
It was like dark and shriveled up.
And then of course the lights going off
like crazy thing thing.
They mended funding,
but they let us do all this.
What they did let us do was call it,
make me hard.
They wanted to call it and make me
stiff.
And that was like a legitimate argument.
So you changed it.
So we had to change it for making it
hard to make any steps to put your foot
down as a period of sentence there.
No,
it's not hard.
It's not the same.
But that's how dumb it is when you're
dealing with network television.
That's how dumb their arguments are.
It's like everybody wants to change
something and they really believe that
they have to change something to get
your respect that you,
you know,
that you're going to have to listen to
them and they want to come in and they
all,
none of them are creative and all the
lawsuits,
that'd be more offensive.
How could the word hard be more
offensive than the word stiff?
That doesn't even make any sense.
Stiff to me sounds like even more like a
pokey,
you know,
like make me hard.
It's like,
oh,
it's like you're a rare and the girl
make me.
Steph is like,
like you're stabbing somebody with it.
You know?
It's like,
don't you want your Dick each?
Get them stepping.
It doesn't sound fun,
but that's all the arguments are men.
It's very lazy gentleman.
We're learning because it kind of hit a
value and be notated value are fairly
educated to the masses.
So giving you knowledge.
Where's the laptop?
It'd be easier to read off the laptop,
get fucking your feet up your internet
week,
but will be fixed tomorrow.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to do this every week.
We're going to start taking some
questions now.
Just twitter feeds come into fucking
fast.
It's crazy.
When your twitter feeds going faster
than chat room.
Usually know she was one of the big news
doors.
Is that Lenny Bruce on the wall?
No,
that's,
that's a picture of me from my first CD.
This dude made it with,
uh,
with snake blood.
Some crazy dudes.
To me it makes paintings with snake
blood and uh,
I uh,
lost that dude's email.
So if he gets to see this dude who makes
paintings with snake blood,
thank you very much for the picture.
Pretty fucking dope.
And it's up.
There was questions are so it's hard to
read this shit man.
What's going on?
The news right now?
Nexus phones coming out for no
terrorism.
Brian.
A fucking fight.
They don't use this kind of phones,
Joe.
These people don't use those phones?
No,
the terrorists.
Oh,
okay.
I don't know what you're saying.
Do do too.
God Damn.
This is impossible to read.
I'm way too high to be reading this
moving shit.
Any updates on the stage moving or what
are you gonna for sure.
There's so many rumors floating around.
I heard this report,
but this doesn't say why I haven't heard
anything official.
I've heard some crazy shit that like
what?
Drinking bleach.
Stabbing himself in the stomach.
Fucking I hope that's not real fingering
his asshole.
What?
Don't make that not the fingernail.
So of course that's not funny.
Overdose overdosing.
Uh,
that wasn't an accurate drinking bleach.
Like he tried to drink like suicide.
That's certainly open to the hospital.
Um,
uh,
just to get a checkup and then it's
overblown.
Did you hear the Howard Stern show this
week?
No,
I haven't heard it at all.
It's probably like old news.
Everyone probably knows what's
happening.
He's cry.
Fine.
Did you hear about Tiger Woods?
I just love saying that.
I don't even have any news.
Did you hear about the new thing with
the whiskey or the um,
the um,
the bottles of vodka and red bull and
the three hot chicks came up to his
room.
He showed the with your pussy maybe he
ordered maybe 20 bottles of vodka
wanting.
In the case of red bull,
I had three really hot chicks up in his
room.
That's how we celebrated New Year's this
year.
This year.
It's also a porn video being shot.
Did.
Where did that come from?
I was in the news,
but he was celebrating.
That's that.
That's how we celebrated New Year's at
TMZ apparently was there.
I thought I got let this house.
I think he just said fuck it.
You know,
this year I could see in the packs and I
think he just said,
fuck it.
I'm tired of this bullshit.
I'm just going to live.
I'm going to live.
My last question for like six months.
It'd be over and I like to fuck people
who's out there who like,
he has so much money that he doesn't
have to work ever again.
Keep working though.
You can keep playing golf,
right?
You can totally play play golf,
but he doesn't need the endorsements.
Which people get the endorsements back.
You'll get different indoors.
So you don't think someone's gonna
sponsor who's winning these tournaments,
but who were they?
Keep showing up on Sunday.
Most of the time.
Let's put our logo on his bag is a lot
of money in that golf.
Huh?
That's a businessman sport.
There's so much money in.
In Big Golf.
Yeah.
It's like no offense you get jeff guys
just doesn't carry as much weight.
Do you think people like go into golf
thinking that you're gonna make money
off without so hard?
I think it's the same as any sport.
Basketball by the major sports,
basketball,
baseball,
football that you go onto a gun,
like I love climbing all star when like
all the conference you can go to a big
division one school in the back of your
head.
You're like,
I want to play pro,
I'm sure.
Right.
But it's just the,
you know,
the hardest thing about becoming a
professional at anything difficult like
role for,
you know,
whatever.
Playing football or any sport.
It's saying,
okay,
this is what I'm going to do.
Because you don't have a fucking backup
plan if that's what you're going to do.
Oh yeah.
It's uh,
it's uh,
it's the uh,
scratcher the guy who just make ties on
tour.
It's got acute school scratch off a
fucking eighth place finish at the best
buy for a grant.
You know,
hopefully just fighters too.
I see some of them for eight and eight.
You find three fights a year,
getting 37 managers see that graphic?
Oh,
Brian's having little conversations.
All of his own.
Someone said winning is everything
cotinus.
Okay.
Would you bang Tiger Woods wife right
now?
I think no,
because she'd be very good
vulnerable and I feel feel bad about
that,
but I would fuck the life out.
Considered a bottle or I think poor
girl,
you know,
she's having a hard time right now
so I have to rape her or she wants to do
it.
She wants to fuck you.
She needs someone to hold her and then
as she's holding you,
you grab her ask and she says nothing
and then just go for it.
You just go for it.
But she doesn't really like grab your
Dick.
You grabbed her hand and put it on your
desk and she just goes with it.
Does she get into it while she's doing
that?
Sort of a little bit because she feels
bad,
so the whole time.
It sounds like a terrible.
I think I'd still then.
I wouldn't be disappointed though.
Yeah,
that'd be very disappointing.
It would leave me with a great feeling.
Yeah.
It wouldn't be the.
She got really into it though.
If she gave it.
Sanger became just a bb plus game.
I think that'd be super pleased.
So much more important to have a chip
that's really into it.
It's so important.
A hardship is not into it,
but there's some port.
There's a point of diminishing returns,
you know,
like a super hot chick who just lays
there is a way,
but it's not as not as good as a one
step down.
It goes crazy,
but it is better than down.
Okay.
Certain point.
There's like a certain at a certain
weight,
certain smell.
So I'm okay.
Okay.
I'll take the hot to check.
That doesn't move.
He,
but that.
The answer it gives you a quarter
credit.
Hotness gives you full credit.
So here's the thing that gets me as
those,
those robot things,
those dolls,
those real dolls.
Would you fuck one of those because I
don't think I would fuck fuck pillows
before,
definitely,
but.
But I'm saying I wouldn't invest a lot
of money.
Rather jerk off and fuck that thing.
I'll try it out.
How your flesh lastly be good.
Do you think that's good?
I don't know.
I mean sometimes lotion feels better
than not.
Motion feels weird.
Here's one thing to fantasize and
masturbate is just another thing to fuck
a rubber.
That's a totally different thing.
I think it feels right.
It's just that the extension that's
three d versus two d that's just gives
you more texture.
True,
but it's a thing.
It's not your imagination.
With auto manipulation,
it's a thing.
You're fucked enough.
I guess.
I grew up in a rubber thing.
It feels good and as you like closing
your eyes.
If you could feel something,
it feels like skin.
Like,
Oh,
here's my point.
It seems much more humiliating if
someone catches you.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Someone catches you fucking have Robert
Dahl.
You feel like shit.
I think you're supposed to feel like
shit.
If someone catches you,
that would be worse.
Well,
that's because I think you're supposed
to feel like shit for doing that.
That's a fucking creepy thing you do
when you fuck it.
A rubber dog.
You weirdo.
You should just jerk off.
Oh,
now we're going to make noise noises.
Actually noises portion of the program
guy says about real dolls day Broomfield
says they look awesome talking.
Taking them to dinner is awkward though.
Did you ever see that movie,
Lars and the real doll?
Oh,
just come as ridiculous.
You know,
if you were somebody that never got laid
like forever.
By the way,
did you guys watch
that conveyor?
Love that show?
No,
it's great.
It's a convenience.
It's a new reality show where I.
Four hot chicks just have a conveyor
belt in front of them and they just send
guys down.
The Guy has like 20 seconds to impress
them or they just go get out of here and
he goes up on the conveyor belt and then
at the end of 100 guys and they take
them on a date and so then like there
was this one takes like,
oh,
I just want that guy.
I want to.
I just want to do him so bad.
It was like a guy with no shirt on and a
puppy and then the next person would be
like a standup comic,
like dude,
like do you like fire and you had like a
fireball coming in because this was
right after,
uh,
the bachelor,
whatever the bachelor.
It was right after the manager at ABC.
ABC.
So what are the four for 10?
No conveyor of love.
I think all the people that choose to go
on dates with him later
and yeah.
And then the dates were off.
Like this one guy is like crazy.
Oh you guys got downloaded.
How incredible is that?
Because when shit got stuck with this
fat guy that had like really ugly hair
by mistake,
because it's a game.
You could steal other people's.
If there's two girls that want the guy
than the guy has to decide between the
two girls and they're just blunt,
like might be the greatest show of all
time.
Oh,
it's great.
It's so bad.
It's just like,
look how much more we can let people to
meet in themselves.
Do you remember that temptation island?
Do you remember?
That shit was hilarious.
That was good too.
How crazy was that?
They would take these fucking chicks and
tell them to try to get these guys to
cheat and film everything they did and
still cheap and they would fuck the
girls.
Is there was a girl who works for fear
factor.
That was one of the girls prostitutes.
Yeah.
Basically.
I mean,
I mean have to be attracted to the.
I don't know.
It's not an American soil.
They're not paying them to fuck them.
They're paying them to flirt,
but the processes with whatever happens,
if something happens,
you just.
Any girl kissing was like,
okay,
stop.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I don't remember watching.
I think that would be highly
discouraged.
Remember Mrs Rogan pink shops at Mrs
Rogan did not like it.
She was like,
oh,
that's terrible.
Show.
So being this week motherfuckers.
They got the weakest.
Dumbest.
The no,
but eventually like buckets.
She just wrecked their lives on TV.
Cheaters is so fake,
by the way.
Did you know that?
She's not always because he got stabbed
for no.
Look at the staff video now.
Look at it now.
It's like watching Iti now and you know,
you see how fake it is.
Have you watched the stabbing video of
cheaters?
Now our brands have gotten past that and
now it's so fake looking like this.
Oh.
And no one's helping them out and he's
just like their sport people just
filming him and stuff and it was just
sitting there.
Yeah,
dude,
it,
it looks like etc.
Watching me now.
Yeah,
you,
you're just like,
that's a fake alien.
That's What it looks.
Google that right now.
And this is the beauty of the internet,
but you turn it off.
We walked with them.
No,
no.
Joey greco from cheaters.
Get stabbed.
The stabbing.
Now I want you guys to look at it like.
All right.
Real know.
How would this really happened?
To the one above it.
Is that the one?
Oh wait,
this one she just getting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cheaters get even is what it is.
When you look it up on youtube,
it's just slow.
my,
my internet is so whack.
I'm wearing a white shirt.
Are You?
I'm wearing trying.
If united though.
That was probably staged first comment
on a first comment on youtube.
The dude says that was probably staged.
I don't see that shit.
We're watching it right now.
Ladies and gentleman,
this is like we're watching two girls.
One cup,
except his shit is alive over the
internet right now.
We're about to watch joey greco.
The one comment says,
I hope joe is going to be okay.
This happened four years ago,
three days ago.
I hope joe is going to bail tech and he
would creepy about that.
I think it's her stuff later person.
She read her posts and either way when
you get your internet hooked up,
we will be able to show them what we're
watching.
just can't do it right.
That will be hooked up next week.
Tomorrow.
Next week's episode.
We're going to do this every week,
folks.
All right,
here's the cheater stay.
Let's watch it from the beginning.
I wasn't really paying attention way.
It's beautifully filmed.
Oh,
some guy gets thrown into the water.
Okay.
Somebody's been stabbed.
By the way.
Hold on,
hold on.
Don't say with the camera.
Didn't help him out.
He's just been stabbed.
That looks real
well.
You gotta think though that if he did
get stabbed,
the guy's a failed actor and he's going
to ham it up.
Even if he did get stabbed and if he
summed it up,
he's got stabbed.
I wouldn't be holding a camera and
stuff.
I'd be like,
alright,
can you.
Can you explain?
Yes.
I'm sure This is available.
You can find this out online.
Okay.
Joey greco was.
I was name is.
Yeah,
that's it.
I gotta be honest with you.
It looks pretty fight.
Okay.
And there's another part.
I had a gas.
Yeah,
there's another part in the video where
they got the guy that stabbed him
right here.
Cheaters host joey greco.
Stabbing was staged,
says paid actor.
look at that.
And this just came out november
sort of district.
So this is a recent findinG.
So there recently finding out that whole
thing was standing.
I told you,
oh my man called it.
Do my brain has gotten past the part
where where I can just tell
a bit on the air for nine years now,
documenting scorned lovers come
confronting their cheating partners in
the act with the camera crew and toe.
It's like an episode of jerry springer
field,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Inside the district reports today,
the stabbing was faked and as has was a
relationship shown on at least one
episode.
Sorry.
There's A siren noise.
A little weirded out by reality.
Blurred websites if those are just made
up.
That's a good point.
Mike,
would you see inside edition.com?
That might not be
be the store,
right?
My internet so week.
Wow.
There's another part where they have the
guy that stabbed him in a choke hold.
If you're in a choke hold,
wouldn't you just his hands just like
this.
Look,
why don't you be like trying to punch
the guy in the face that's has you in a
choke hold or tryIng to undo the.
His arms like this and the guys that
hasn't been a choke hold his arms to his
side not doing anything.
Yeah.
This ain't shit.
Okay.
Investigates cheaters is it all hooks
each week,
millions of viewers,
blah,
blah.
Every episode,
blah,
blah.
Bobby goldstein and shows owners is
adamant that every episode is real bad.
Bobby goldstein,
you're so full of shit.
Bobby goldstein.
You're a fucking liar,
dude.
Bobby goldstein.
This shows owner and executive producer
is adamant that every episode is real.
Yes.
You're showing real people.
those are real people.
They're not holograms.
They're not thrilled,
but they're acting mother fucker.
Come on man.
There's the internet.
There's some reshot scenes left and
right on that show.
It's obvious noW the popular up the fuck
up or I was going to say it.
Fuck,
is she talking about?
That's the inside edition abroad.
It's probably interesting.
It's printed here.
That's a goddamn lie.
Let that load up.
Mostly what you have to say.
My mom's internet,
joe,
I did.
This is just one of the websites on the
web cam.
I've got No juice.
I got nothing.
The whole thing was fabricated.
Correct.
Says wyatt.
Alright,
so it's not real at all.
As carrie wyatt who tells inside edition
she was paid $500 to appear in an
episode of cheaters.
She said she was asked to pretend that
she was having a torrid affair with one
guy.
She was while she was engaged to
another.
Huh?
Well,
that's a different story though.
That's what they're saying.
Against what?
That guy said,
that every episode is real.
They're Just breaking that.
What he's saying is faith.
oh,
will you hold
inside edition?
your website sucks.
It is really that sort of the slope you
have to hit hit on this little.
Put your cursor over this arrow to Get
your text.
Just scroll down.
I wonder if this is lick.
You fall from that other guy's website.
I wonder if this is all fake dude
looking at inside edition as the worst
website ever.
Look,
it's flash based.
Do you have to hold your cursor over the
fucking hateful ass?
I'm done with flat.
This is the weakest thing I've ever
seen.
Or you can't take it.
Scroll down.
No,
you can't do.
You can't use your score.
You have to use their stupid thinG and
you have to figure it out.
I thought that that was the whole
article because it was.
It's actually cut off.
It doesn't even say more at the bottom.
Shame on you inside edition.
Your arTicles.
Your whole website sucks,
so we're going to move off of it bitch,
but I'm.
I think I think I would have to go with
that was a hoax.
Totally.
Every time we watch when he's getting
choked and just wants his arm.
Now,
if you're getting choked or not,
arms not just going to be like gently
resting on your side.
Hold on.
This fellow johnny bananas has a
question.
Says,
what do you think about the suicide
bomber?
That was a cia double agent.
What the fuck is he talkiNg to them
about?
Have chem trails and Jordan.
Oh,
the guy who kIlled all the cia people.
He was a double agent.
Is that what it was approved by the
jordanians,
jordanians or drainage or banners.
And he was a cia agent as well.
Yeah,
and I don't know.
He killed a bunch of like really high
level guys.
there it goes.
Something like the news stories he
killed,
he was recruited through the jordanians
and they're like,
no,
the Jordan has never got it back.
Or I don't know was.
I can't.
I'm so high.
Can type.
I'm googling the cia.
Suicide bomber news ticker.
This is some crAzy shit.
ladies and gentlemen,
look at this guys.
That's marijuana sodie pop route buzz.
It's um,
I don't like it.
I like the feeling.
It's um,
it's one of those almost like narcotic
feelings.
Yeah.
One of the sodas.
I don't like edibles as much anymoRe.
Period.
and yeah,
I don't feel like tripping.
I just want to get a little high and
thinking about some shit.
I don't want to invest that much.
Last day.
THis is crazy shit.
There was a dude who is a cia double
agent and use the suicide bomber himself
up and a bunch of shit.
So he was,
what does that mean?
Double agent while he was working for
the cia,
pretending to be a cia and also working
for,
I guess al qaeda and the taliban or
whoever the hell it is.
We sent him to blow everybody out,
but he was a cia agent.
He was in.
Where was it?
Where did it happen?
It's loading up.
I think it said Jordan Shepherd a local.
yeah,
I guess
cia operatives killed by double agent.
That's pretty intense shit,
man.
Suicide bomber killed seven,
seven central intelligence agents.
Agency operatives in Afghanistan last
week was a jordanian double agent who
lured them into a meeting by promising
information on al qaeda leaders,
a form of us intelligence officials set.
So they,
he lured them in and just blew himself
up.
Had got them to come to him.
He's going to give them some information
and they're all in the room.
He just went to a restaurant with a year
ago by jordanian authorities who thought
they had convinced them to work for
them.
So the jordanians thought they had
gotten him to work for jordanians.
Wow.
They thought they can and good guys.
Yeah,
but how the fuck.
Well supposedly you know,
how the fuck did they talk him into
doing that?
He goT arrested a year ago or a year
abroad riding good intelligence.
God damn.
What are.
or that guy as.
Huh?
He gets friends with them,
get them all on a room and then goes and
just does the whole thing.
Just fucking blows himself up.
How crazy is that?
Oh,
this is brian's new kitty.
You got to see this folks.
Brian scott knew kitty cat.
Let me see this fucking glare.
Can you say it is a short haired
persian.
So it,
it brung exotic,
sort of,
too much glare from this stupid little.
Oh,
this
um,
somebody goes into my,
uh,
girlfriend's work as a breeder.
Said she had kittens,
jessica,
one entity and I was thinking just
kittens and then
she showed me.
I was like,
oh my god.
That's like a real cat.
Had to get it as opposed to like a tom
cat type thing.
We had such a good time with the 10 hour
chat.
Our preferred myself,
catholic friends.
Well my cat is a front.
Yeah,
job friends.
It's cool when there's like life all
around you to.
When you're at home and you're anywhere
you go,
there's something going on,
like a creatures like trying to create
something or do something.
That's what I feel living on sunset.
This man says,
joey greco is not his real name.
Wow.
Well that doesn't matter.
Well,
It doesn't matter.
No.
he's a lot of changes in age.
Like carlos,
when ceos fucking the fuck are.
We should fear.
How many times do people mispronounced
your name?
Oh,
it's.
But that's your fucking name.
Sign.
That's a part of the change of name.
You should never changed the name.
Arnold schwarzenegger is arnold swartz
and maybe that's part of the flavors.
He's got this fucked up name.
That's part of the thing.
It may.
It defines who you are.
Here's,
here's the thing about cheater.
start watching it and just notice how.
There's never really good lunches.
There's never a good punches when the
fight.
Bob dylan,
bob dole,
a time it kegan stein.
See bob dylan.
He's a fucking south haven because good.
It could have been good at their job.
They just stuck with his name with.
What'd you say?
It was already taken.
If you stuck with julie kagan state and
just still rocked the house,
just that hard.
Maybe they would've just said,
you know what?
Look jess.
Java became famous and she was fat and
ugly as fuck.
She had a big fat,
stupid face.
I'm telling You the office example.
I'm not even making sense.
I mean,
I might even go to the heart of the
archeologists.
Her fucking name itself is cool.
I like wearing makeup.
Nissan's talk about security,
arguing.
That's the chem trail.
Crop trails argument.
Just tell you something else and be
like,
okay,
that's right man.
I watched a documentary last night on
ancient aliens on the history channel I
ordered on dvd.
It's eddie bravo is just always
constantly talking about aliens,
aliens.
It's like there's.
There comes a certain point in time when
someone is so obsessed with aliens.
you run the risk of once you're married,
the risk of not wanting to even consider
aliens anymore.
He was like,
son,
it's not real.
It's not possible,
but it's so possible.
It's possible.
It's more possible when you watCh these
videos,
these ancient alien videos where they
talked about these ancient structures
and you know what technology put these
together.
I think if you just look around at the
evidence,
there's not that much evidence that
aliens have landed,
but there's a lot of evidence that life
on this planet has been fucking
seriously jacked,
at least three or four times,
like big ones that we know about.
Extinctions on mass extinctions happened
to the car from inside the house.
Jeff assessment management.
This is my management.
They don't even knoW that I'm fucking
out a podcast.
I would,
I would think to just suspend management
would be aware of my podcasting from
three to five.
unused stream today.
It started at 3:30,
shandra.
Well
that's the best way.
We're all going to be become one on
twitter.
I'm on the podcast,
so I'll call you later.
Bye.
That was my manager,
shandra.
Very necessarily.
She's on a twitter.
She said that's how she finds out my,
uh,
I schedule.
I don't even talk to my manager.
He just twitter,
just real talk.
I talked to them occasionally.
Sometimes I'm elusive.
Separate.
Stung a little bit,
huh?
Let's take some questions from the
field.
Ladies and gentlemen.
What am I going to educate dana on
copYright?
Well,
I am a retard,
I'm not educating anybody on anything
but copyright law I think is the ufc is
threatening to sue all these people to
take illegal downloads of the.
Of the same saying,
yeah,
they're just doing well.
They're talking about putting people in
jail and the threat of that is enough to
make some examples and stuff.
They're going to throw some people in
what the.
The,
the la guy fit them on clots doors,
the la sheriff,
whatever.
They're like,
you're going to shut out all 900.
It goes to shut down a few clothes.
He's right to know who's going to risk
going to jail or they're just going on
the block and there was a dude that.
It was in med school that was a selling.
He was an all licensed and legal and
everything like that,
but he decided it was too risky and it's
like,
you think it's like,
no,
obama won.
It's not.
You never know.
There's a lot of people kind of
interpret the law.
You know?
The interesting thing is it's Moving
along.
There's a tuesday,
the twelfth or some vote in California.
It's on the message board where they're
talking about,
uh,
trying to,
vote to move towards legalizing it.
I'm not a registered voter register.
You got to participate in their fake
game after obama.
I swear to god.
I thought before obama was in office,
I was like,
you know what?
This is going to be very different.
We have a black guy,
he's a liberal.
I'm like the very least,
it'll be good for the consciousness of
the country.
They'll have a leader there,
have someone to look up to that's more
peaceful and has their shit together or
can speak better and it's black and it's
been through a rough childhood and
everything,
but he's doing the same ship.
The elder,
he's doing the same exact shit.
It's almost like they have all these
ideas and then they get into office.
Oh,
it's not as easy to make it happen,
but it's not just go along with things
like sending the troops to Afghanistan
saying it's extra $30,000
at certain points.
He realized what choice do I have?
I can just plug it out,
make it a huge vacuum in this drawer
itself.
If that's true,
then I realized I could make this
problem on it's way past the year.
Fuck,
you know,
well,
not way past,
but it's certainly more trips,
but they talk about how it would become
a hotbed for terrorist.
And we left.
It's a hot bed now.
It's the whole.
That whole middle east is mad at us.
That whole middle east is mad at us and
it's like now it's like once you start
bullying someone and you start pushing
them,
once they go down,
you got to keep pushing up.
You know,
that's what's going on right now.
You got to keep them down.
No,
fuck you gotta.
Keep them now because if they rise up
and they go get something to eat and
they take a nap and they come back with
fresh,
they're going to punch you in the
fucking face.
You know,
you're gonna,
you're gonna walk out of a restaurant
and the guy's going to be right there.
Hey,
I want to talk about what we had to talk
about earlier.
I heard this thing and here are the
people that have been released now and
that,
uh,
Yemen,
um,
and they're worried about them,
you know,
re integrating.
The problem is no one gave them jobs
there because they're like whatever.
And they're getting,
becoming disillusioned and leaning on
people like ocado and saying,
well help me.
It's like there's newly being recruited,
like maybe they were wrongly accused
before,
but it's like,
so it's like their life is such shit.
No one gives me the right direction.
They don't just become angry because I
can't get a job.
I'm fucking wasted eight years of my
life.
What am I supposed to do with someone
else
is offering you jobs and telling you all
this stuff.
That sounds right.
A place to live.
Could you fucking imagine,
could you imagine how lucky you are and
that you were born in the middle of it?
I bet in plays like a substance only
comes around once a day.
What was it like?
What must it like to be pregnant?
To be a pregnant woman living in
Afghanistan?
How crazy my staff be?
The feeling of vulnerability,
the constant stress and shaking,
I mean that would be just absolutely
horrifying.
Tuesday,
january 12,
members of California,
that's what they always do.
Dude.
California assembly will hold the
historic vote on statewide marijuana
policy.
Members of the public safety committee
will decide on assembly bill three 90,
the marijuana control regulation and
education act,
which seeks to regulate and control the
production distribution and personal use
of marijuana for adults older.
All these things are just wide open,
so it's really open to interpretation.
You know,
no cache,
no.
It's like what?
And then they really want to narrow it
down.
Now what's legal,
what's not legal,
and if they did open it up illegally,
statewide,
it wouldn't be much different.
It's very easy to get a recommendation.
The recommendations of the problem,
the taxes was selling the pot while
there.
There's always going to be about whether
or not doctors giving us,
but with these guys what they're saying
is they're trying to legalize it.
This is not about medical.
this is about legalization for personal
use.
This is a totally different situation.
They're talking about taxing it and
trying to make money out of it.
It's a regular to regulate and control
the production distribution personally.
Yeah.
It's not magical.
They're not talking about medical
marijuana.
Federally.
Medical marijuana doesn't exist and
that's,
that's what fucks you.
That's what happened to todd mccormick.
When he got arrested,
he got to court and in court they told
him that you can't even use the term
medical marijuana
have wacky is up.
You can't even say it.
You can't even say that I want to.
And you go,
yes,
I was selling marijuana under,
you know,
the assumption that you know,
it was legal because proposition to 50.
They don't.
They don't want to hear a fucking word
of that big.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
Were you selling marijuana?
yeah.
Good.
Brody.
What does this cohost tell us?
What is this?
He that means that he can be in a camera
on the side.
His face.
It was this guy bernie stevens.
That's brody,
isn't it?
No,
no,
nevermind.
Boredom.
Boredom strikes.
What are you blind?
I am blind now.
Can't I can't go of my rehearsal.
And I was like,
my internet could handle it.
Cohost.
How do you just.
Somebody gives just anybody but on that.
Well now we know.
Now we know that you can try to comment
if you have somebody that's going to
want to be like,
oh yeah,
sure.
It's considered with let's say got a
million people were requesting it.
Oh,
then that'll go crazy.
You need direct line.
I think
eventually everyone's gonna have their
own reality show.
That's my,
my vision of the apocalypse.
is it?
We're all going to have a chat.
We'll all have a channel.
I mean basically that's what we're doing
right now.
Well once you get the internet,
you could have up to six co where anyone
could have there I think have their face
on the side and you can just mute them.
But if you want to ask him a question,
you joined him in on the conversation
but you,
we're waiting on your internet.
Oh shit.
So we could have like an interview like
mayhem and stuff like that.
Oh that would be beautiful.
You could have a bunch of people in iT.
We have a bunch of windows and they
could all open up the different windows
and they'd be watching all the same time
when we could move it like,
like,
like hollywood squares will go to go to
whoopi goldberg.
Right?
What big desktop?
Like overlaid on ms.camp.
We went to see showcase things are
getting crazy.
Pretty cool,
right?
Just thinking about 10 years ago you
couldn't even do something like this.
No,
there was nothing.
There was no twitter,
there was no.
The webcam shows we just blurry pictures
of fucked up girl showing you their
pussy and you had to be in their
membership to get that right.
Slow down.
Those bItches went out of business with
the internet.
They blossomed those cam girls.
But then that shit just rotting on the
vine.
I say that though because you remember
when you used to have like that one cam
girl and it would be like a whole group
of people that were all just like,
look at this.
She's gonna,
you know?
Well you know,
it was really cool.
Is that crazy?
Amber chick?
She was a really cool.
there was a modern day like,
like,
well this,
this to do real porns her boyfriend do
porns and put them on the internet.
She didn't give a fuck.
I folloWed this one where it was a girl
that just had a camera on 24 hours a day
and it was just her and her husband
living in New York,
but they would have fucking straight up
when they had sex,
they would have sex right on the camera.
But other than that it was just been
living their life 24 hours a day.
Wow.
Holy shit.
And now she,
uh,
got stopped that and now she's a
successful author and she's trying to
raise her past.
No one knows who really did anybody save
the video of her and her husband.
Fucking google cache is wonders.
And I'm not gonna.
Say her name now.
What'd you say?
Cash wanders.
Google cash.
Cash.
if you go to google and type in internet
history,
there's a thing that comes up.
I called the wayback machine and you
could type in your website and see what
it looked like back in like 1985.
IncredibLe.
Yeah.
Google is fucking,
we were just talking about this,
me and my tech friend that wire's my
house.
He was like,
google was like,
they have so much power.
It's almost like if,
if google were evil,
like we wouldn't even see them coming
and they document everything.
You know,
like if there's an artificial
intelligence out there,
it's google.
You know,
google is a weird company man.
I mean there are so powerful.
If they do terminator,
they do mail,
they do searching,
they do your fucking maps.
They do what your house looks like from
space.
I think longitude is the scariest one,
the one where it just tracks where you
are throughout the whole day.
So you could look at it and see like,
oh I was here,
here,
here the whole day.
And it records that information,
puts it in some kind of database to see
where people are going.
You know.
It's like fuck,
it's fucking crazy that you would ever
sign up for that too.
It's fucking crazy man.
The whole google thing.
But you know,
they seem like a nice company and that's
why.
That's by the way,
that's why gps on the google phone is
kind of scary because if you use google,
what is google doing with that
information?
Because they could.
There's a way for them to use that
information.
If you're using your g maps,
you know,
talking about where people are growing
and when they're going.
Right.
It's,
yeah,
you're running it through google now
you're running a gps through.
YOu know what's really Cute though?
What if they were evil and they decided,
well let's just give a lovable name like
google,
right?
Colorful.
We work really hard and work really hard
on being green and eco conscious and we,
we really pay our employees.
Well they're all swell,
but they're just ruthless monsters.
What if it's the government?
What if it is to.
That's like area 57 brands.
No shit like developed.
They figured the boycott because of they
sat down,
what have they said
down and looked at the trends that
humanity is participating in,
like look where things are going
technologically and said,
you know what?
And they got the best scientists on it
and they said,
this is where we think things are going.
We think things are going to,
uh,
an online based email service so you can
access it from multiple ports.
We think things are going to.
And they just started listing all these
things and goals.
Okay.
What if it's people from the future
making sure we're going along the right
path?
What if mr.
G's was trying to save us the whole
time.
He was just like this butler trying to
be our friend.
It was like fucking hell.
I have ounces.
How many hits has asked jeeves get a
day.
I don't know.
But when remember when.
Remember web crawler?
No,
it used to be like a pre web crawler.
I kind of remember
that now.
Barely.
I don't remember.
I remember realizing that I didn't have
to get online through aol.
That was a great day.
Wasn't a lot.
There's another thing I was like,
oh my god.
But that's like space.
That's like the wilderness,
a browser,
and I'm going to go on my own and how do
I get my email?
Now I have to write all that shit into a
program and they get it from the oh wow.
That was for when you first figured out.
You didn't have to use internet explorer
or firefox or something else.
I just went under date a few months ago.
They finally closed shop.
Isn't it crazy?
Once on top of the world,
once huge now irrelevant and so quickly
within a decade gone,
you know,
so much technology and so much.
Some of the things that that were
invented like,
like cds and just have this really short
life,
like there's gonna come a point in time
and no one gives a fuck.
Yeah.
Flash drives hold a fuck load more and
everything's going to have a usb ports
shut up.
You know,
It's like cds or like really hot chicks
that got old.
You know,
like now they have no power or laser
disc.
Poor lasers,
laser disc full.
It was a big laser disc fan.
He used to have like even when laser
disc was dying,
he was buying up really good movies like
terminator,
but it'd be better if it can't be better
visual quality.
Then blue ray though is not better in
blu ray,
but it was better than cd,
uh,
say hi.
It's kind of like hoW records were
better than cd,
but it's better than dvd
image wise.
Yeah.
but it sounds better too
on a blue ray.
So insane hd.
So I was saying anything and you know,
in movies and hd now it's just getting
so crazy.
This fucking avatar man.
Wait till you see this shit who
like visually it's like whoa.
I didn't even see through a lot of
people.
I know it said that they wouldn't go
back in.
That really lived there.
Whatever.
That's what I said.
I said,
all right,
fuck that feature.
Now that we're going to have fucking
mask or wires in our brains are like,
pick avatar,
19 years
cold place to go places.
What do I think of coast to coast with
art bell.
That's the greatest fucking radio show
in the history of the universe,
man.
They would always,
every now and then it get some lame
sidekick on target.
Stupid shit.
But for the most part,
it's all people that new big foot and do
what you used to be werewolves,
but they go.
And by the way,
if you want to know more about what they
were talking about,
go to ask.
Gee,
it's an answer.
Google conspiracies first link will tell
you all about it.
Oh,
there's a conspiracy side about it.
Conspiracy.
Well see,
this is the thing.
Great minds think alike.
Whoever you are out there thinks like us
from November 22nd,
2002 were so lame.
That was eight years ago.
We were Just chilling,
man.
You not believe what I figured out,
bro.
you fuckinG keeps it cold and last
longer.
Fuck it last longer.
Like growing on it.
Good
for you.
I said if you keep it cold,
it lasts longer and so dumb.
Of course There had to be a million
people.
People think there's a conspiracy and
everything.
Those are the nine slash 11 people.
men did.
Those are hard fucking conversations.
You're.
Here's the conversation.
It's always like,
but maybe in a night just to nap,
but maybe it doesn't mean anything.
Well,
the problem Is if it was really,
but maybe I'll have that conversation
with you,
you know,
if you say maybe the government,
really arrange that building to be blown
up.
Maybe bears arranged it,
but,
but you know,
when,
when someone says maybe,
but the problem is they don't say that
they go,
maybe the government doesn't give a fuck
you and they plotted
this and they're attached to that idea.
They don't know if it happened.
There's information that I'm not even
saying it.
It's like fucking.
Do you believe that it sound like you do
quit saying maybe I think they did this.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think they Just know that that's a
ridiculous argument.
it's too hard.
Nobody knows what the fuck happened.
But the idea that it was some gigantic
fucking conspiracy that thousands and
thousands of people are,
you know,
I'm not sure that a few people didn't
know that something was gonna happen,
but the idea that this many people had
to be together and put what the fuck are
you doing?
I don't know.
My phone jusT started crying.
Your phone's gay as fuck.
And I'm not going to even say what was
that?
Oh,
that's what it was.
An alarm was an along.
Well,
what song was it not only talking about.
Just tell me I didn't download.
It was alright.
It was a funny lady.
Gaga.
That is embarrassing.
You hear carmen?
Carmen,
do you like it?
Why did your grill put lady gaga on your
phone?
It's my phone connects to my car,
so whenever we getting in car and he's
like kind of like our jukebox and so she
throws music on my phone all the time.
My girlfriend put another some modern
day.
I ran into a wall what?
And ate my homework.
It's fine.
You liked lady gaga?
She,
I appreciate because she can.
She actually knows how to play our
instruments and she doesn't live.
She's a real musician.
Oh my god.
All that hermaphrodite talk.
It's just like,
it's just more playing it up for the
media.
Very interesting.
How people bite into that.
That one song though gives me fucking
brain cancer,
sarah cart with something that was so
bad thing on my mind to it later to.
And then you actually could hear the
words when he says it.
So it's like there's never been a better
tv show themselves.
Consider funny,
consistent or irreverent consistently
brilliant.
So they get away with shit that no one
get away with that horror off.
When that gay dude stuff.
ParIs hilton,
asshole,
mr helper.
That's the greatest moment in television
history as far as I'm concerned.
The fact they even got away with that,
the fact that they went there,
but that's where you go.
If you're going to go crazy crazy,
that's where you go.
And then at the end he shoves her up his
ass and wins the contest.
Fuck man.
Can we really put that on tv?
But because of these blocky cartoons,
they got away with it.
And because comedy central knows that
they're monsters,
they're Just unstoppable.
People want to watch for.
I don't think comedy central gets to
tell them what to do at all.
I think.
Well yeah,
I think there's a lot of that.
I think they're just like,
shut the fuck.
I think it's not cable.
It's just them side.
We,
we figured that advertising my pull
away,
they haven't an article from south park.
They're branding themselves to this
thing,
so everyone goes knows,
okay,
it might be something like this movie's
success behind them,
so and that movie's success.
Those two big huge films,
those both films were giant successes.
I don't know if they were financially,
but I think they were in America now.
That was one of my favorite movies ever
and they hate it.
They said that was the hardest movie
era.
They will never do that ever again
because it's really time consuming,
but man,
that was such a great marketing genius
and I believe that,
that it was really time consuming,
but it was so god damn good.
I got to see the puppets in real life.
Even the silliness that they're really
the time just kidding catheter because
their size are just close the whole
thing.
Black kittens to be kidding of it with
the fucking terrorists.
He was the funniest I've ever seen
before.
That was probably like the safe sex and
naked gun when they're covered in
rubber,
you know,
but it's like there's no funny.
That was hilarious.
OwnIng hardcore,
did you see the unedited version where
they dropped blogs on each other?
A pps that wasn't in the movie.
Now they cut it from the movie,
otherwise was to ax pee and poop or no
go.
So he threw up and never stopped.
Throwing covered an entire block was so
funny.
I remember crying,
laughing.
I couldn't believe how funny it was.
I was like,
I can't believe they pulled that first
south park a little bit and I was like,
okay.
We go and I was like,
wait.
They're saying,
oh my gosh.
they did a musical a musical and I loved
it and they did a great job,
but how do you do a musical?
That was a genius show.
Blame Canada.
Come on.
How good was that?
How about all the canadians were their
heads pop off?
She'll say,
I'll look completely weird.
Different heads and totally different
than just the fact that we accept that
as a,
hey,
this is connected and bottle it up and
that way.
Except that we.
Okay,
that's the head.
There's the head.
That shit's genius.
That shows so goddamn good.
Like I waS looking at a cartoon the
other day that the one that you gave me,
the barney rubble picture,
barney rubble doesn't have eyeballs.
No black.
He's tripped out black pupils,
but everybody else on the show had
eyeballs because his pupils are black.
Bonnie rubble?
No,
he's tall white.
It's all white.
He's got nothing.
I know.
What about what's that?
Are fruity pebbles doesn't have it?
Well,
I think,
well,
I don't know,
maybe in fruity pebbles yet.
I didn't even know he was off fruity
pebbles.
I thought that was bam.
Bam.
And it's all right.
It's all the moment.
I think so awful experts and the
flintstones pebble,
but it's just weird.
Like you just,
you just get comfortable with the fact
that his face look like that.
So like that.
This avatar movie,
after an hour,
I didn't care that chick was blue and
looked like a lizard.
I still wanted to fuck her.
you went through it?
Yeah,
man.
I wanted to fuck her and which.
And if I lived with them I would know.
But if I lived with them in the woods
and shit,
I would totally thinks she was hot.
I totally motherfucker,
you know,
it's like,
it's subjective.
But if she made a sound other than
english,
I wouldn't want to fuck her.
But yeah,
I love it.
I was a member of the show,
be the old survey or whatever,
and they started like never watched that
show.
Which the show I would not watch the
news.
This guy wants to know this da seven,
eight fella.
He wants to know.
Who do you think is better in bed?
Oprah or hillary clinton?
Hillary clinton runs you think so that's
a hillary clothes.
I have a pushy oprah winfrey is a
fucking huge lesbian.
You think so?
Yes.
Really their friends more than one who
thinks like seemed like moral.
More of a lesbian.
She seems like more.
She made it.
She didn't know,
but she was sexy and made a human.
So she knows she.
She's at least accepted dick.
You have no idea.
We have no idea that steadman guy,
because there was ever a man that looked
like a beard.
That poor.
Fuck dude.
I bet.
If you google oprah winfrey,
guys married old ladies,
do conspiracy theory.
I can see it happen.
That's why ellen wanted to be on the
cover with her.
Well,
she's super powerful,
man.
Maybe.
Maybe she's so powerful that the
testosterone that she asked for having
like a billion dollars,
the surge of power that she has maybe
just made her just want to dominate some
pitches.
Maybe she doesn't even.
Maybe oprah only gets them to eat her
pussy.
Her hair.
She doesn't put the shit up,
doesn't do shit.
Is worth a billion dollars and she hangs
out with these brokerages.
That's this oprah.
Do you know how much I believe that's a
thousand dollars.
Million.
That's incredible money.
That's an insane amount of money.
She's so rich.
Do you couldn't spend that?
You would have to go nutty if you want
to spend that and she's probably worth
more than a billion.
She's probably worth several billion.
Right?
So pro fucking winfrey.
She Just kept coming out and new stuff.
No one's been ever been more successful
than oprah winfrey.
Like for daytime tv though.
I still remember the old old school.
Oprah.
What's the question?
I love this question.
Let's read it like how he writes it or
she.
This guy.
Yo,
what's your ethnicity?
You bond into religion.
Says,
yo,
whaT's your ethnicity?
Where you born into a religion?
that's not a bad question if you're 18.
Ashley brio.
Ashley bryan.
Oh,
so this is what twitter does.
It doesn't actually scroll.
It just bumps.
But you know when new people leaving.
Oh it does scroll.
Look a little better,
but it's really far.
What do they have to
put hashtags on it and you follow the
hashtags?
I don't know.
I don't know why it's doing that.
That's what I was looking at earlier.
They'll put in the hashtags on,
is that what it is?
No.
Hashtag.
That's exactly what it is,
is hashtags,
but why is it doing that?
That's weird.
But why isn't it doesn't have a little
app style?
What does it mean?
Does it mean they're in this twitter
room?
Is that what it is?
Check my iphone.
A young hillary clinTon.
What do you think young hillary clinton
was?
Was cool.
Adam.
The first time we ran it was like,
no,
I don't think by then she she'd had a
child.
Who would you rather fuck now?
Is that the story that you think is
better and better?
I question,
but it wasn't hillary.
Hillary,
hillary would give you some actioN.
Whereas oprah would make it either
pushing.
Hillary would have better cocaine.
I'm just not july.
That's what oprah would winfrey really
did.
She just had girls eat her pussy.
That's hilarious.
They came out just like tiger woods
coming out that he's a freak and he's
married with children,
but it's really banging like 16
different chicks at the same time.
what if it came out that oprah winfrey,
it's just crazy bitch that just has all
these young girls eat her pussy and
they're all blindfolded.
They bring it into a special room so
they don't know who's putting their
writing.
Like,
this is your rule.
This is your assignment.
You will be paid $125,000
a month.
Will you accept?
You know,
you keep getting that much.
You'd have to give him 125 a year,
but she,
she will call upon,
you know,
got more than that.
If you Want to be like not blindfold and
just go into a room,
they eat your pussy hundred 25 a year
and still be on call at all times on
call.
That's too much.
You can retire.
I can't keep you.
My bitch you have to do is work for a
couple years ago.
I'm tired.
I want to keep you my bitch.
I'll give you get used to money,
but you can't really hold enough away
and we're going to do it from my car to
take someone who's super broke.
Started off at 75,
35 percent increase year.
Started them off 50,
but you got to get a super bowl next
year.
Like I want to leave.
Not because the grant,
the next year I will give you 75.
Oh,
you're after that.
I want to leave.
It all depends on year.
Okay.
Now I want to live $300.
He's out in june.
Me right now.
Just keep.
Not letting them leave.
It's like hollywood.
You can never ever get to a certain
point.
You have to be cultivating other boys
and getting used to the mother's slave.
Reforestation.
Yeah.
You get them used to the money and then
look,
you want to talk some shit after over
there is ready to become a number one
boy and hector hector like sucking dick
hillside.
Three,
four hillside.
My friends dick.
If I got some guy he looks like he's one
of the unique metAl 29 hit the road and
hector is have to suck dick all the way
from Guatemala to get here is so happy
to have a fresh pair.
The keys
will suck the life out of your balls.
Hackers here,
you see her for you.
Totally.
Right.
So the competition and being a male
whore.
You know in Nevada they just recently
approved male horse.
They're going to have nail horrors for.
No apparently didn't.
Apparently it was only females.
What?
That's crazy.
Why would they not have it?
That seems.
That's interesting.
I don't know.
It doesn't seem worse.
This is the wait,
wait guys.
For society,
if guys think they're fred is gay,
they're going to get them a male horn.
Now I'm like,
dude,
you're not gonna.
Believe real for your birthday to a
fucking whore.
The bloody rags.
Get the fuck outta here.
That'd be a nice moment because you're
like,
oh,
I've got to fake it with this girl from
my friends.
Sure.
Imagine you get an award.
The bunny ranch is going to go,
and I wrote,
what is,
what does she look like?
Don't worry.
You're going to Like it to send them in
there and then the red light comes on.
It's a naked guy with a heart on.
It's like,
oh my god,
could you imagine what that is going to
be?
The guy says,
what the fuck?
You know that he's just a little femi.
Please quit wearing sweaters.
My dad had a friend when I was growing
up,
I would have swore this dude was gay,
but he wasn't gay.
It was just a little friendly.
Yeah.
It's like,
look,
if you didn't know duncan trussell,
there are times when duncan trussell
can I ask family,
but I just think that I couldn't act
serious and normal stuff like that,
but I just always let myself like,
who cares,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
You're not understanding me.
That's not me.
That's relaxed.
This guy was like,
god,
I kind of famous.
People are always gay.
Really?
Well,
can you just go into it?
Yeah.
Why is it doing hashtags?
And that's a better question.
Why It works.
That's fucked up,
dude.
To try to fix it now.
I don't want to fuck anything up,
but I'll try it.
Does anyone know why it's doing hashtags
instead?
The signs in the twitter.
Social stream on ustream?
Yeah,
because they're socializing about the
subject.
yeah.
Well it's last week.
Last week I did at signs and that's what
we want.
We don't want this hashtag bullshit.
Anyone know how to change shape from two
hash hash tags to add signs.
I'm still doing the same thing.
Duncan trussell is awesome.
yes.
When he goes,
he's really just playing fucking legs.
Girls.
trust me.
What's that red van?
the karma grip.
Done dunkelman.
He's technically a comic.
He had go up anytime he wants.
He wants to fuck around.
He's very funny.
Actually wrote some good materIal.
We have to get it.
Uh,
when we're going to.
I can't tell you about that.
I'm just going to tell them about the
show thing.
Can't tell you what though.
But uh,
he's done it a bunch of times.
It's just doing these videos even though
it doesn't seem like it takes a lot of
time.
It takes a lot of fucking time.
And he's got an archive.
This god damn materials
doing open mic sucks ass that to the
product he,
he like puts me in front of him on his
sold out shows and I'm like a newb
trying to do comedy,
but you get spoiled and then you have to
go to the.
When you go back to la and you go in
front of like three other comics,
you know,
and he spent four hours a day just so
you can have,
you know,
five minutes on stage.
It sucks.
Yeah.
Open mic.
So that shit.
I'm too old for that.
You know,
they're brutal.
It's a little warm.
Yeah.
Water.
I'll be right back.
We've got cotton mouth.
So they'll entertain you guys try to
change the hashtag or are they all doing
it?
They're all putting it in.
It is because what are the new videOs
coming up?
We're logged into your stream via our
twitter account.
Where your videos coming up?
Growing.
What videos?
What do you got coming on in your life?
I'm not really doing much of videos
right now.
Really is doing a new thing where he's
doing before a show on the road every
time.
Uh,
he makes a video specifically for that
town.
Like he has material from austin?
Yeah.
If you go see joe do standup at most
places nowadays we have a thing called
death squad that's like before the show,
it's just kind of collection of videos
and we film a bunch of stuff.
Like,
hey,
we're coming to austin.
It's kind of centered around that city.
So
she get there at least 15 minutes before
showtime to watch that stuff.
What's that?
Oh,
the videos.
Yeah,
yeah,
we're going to do that in most places we
go to when I will be shown just that
week.
And then dOn't.
Yeah,
when I go like to like one nighters,
like dc,
like ari and I are doing dc this,
um,
next sunday,
this upcoming sunday.
Brian'S not going to come with us to
that one,
but when we do weekends,
like the next week was the next weekend.
Dod to addison will probably do it.
Tempe,
no ice house prior to the next one?
Yeah.
Ice house.
And then addison and tempe.
It's all up on my twitter page.
Oh,
it's right in front of me asking you
questions.
The icehouse addison and then tempe.
Addison's.
I'm looking forward to that.
I fucking love Texas.
How much fun is Texas?
I love Texas.
So much fun.
I'm looking at those dates on like
templates.
Going to be a lot of fun.
Always is an ice house is always a lot
of fun.
But my man will go,
you know,
it's like the food's a little better.
The people were a little more fun.
It's a little more rowdy.
It's like the like healthier.
There's something about them to like,
they got something that we don't have
here in California.
This,
this place is so polluted By the
entertainment business,
but yet I hate the east coast.
East coast to angry.
Yeah.
why?
Why is it so angry?
So fucking mad.
You know,
I grew up witH a lot of guys like that.
Always in everyone's insulting and
they're usually the funniest guys
because they have to learn quickly to
deal with,
you know,
people's bullshit.
But boston,
boston,
so fucking agra.
So many aggro guys.
Yeah.
Everybody's upset.
Everybody wants to fight in New York.
How could he?
I can't living around
that many people's rough.
So many people.
It's someone saiD just this guy t saps
said because it's cold.
That is definitely part of it.
Boston is cold as fuck in the winter.
I was there in october and when I was
there in october it was starting to be
freezing cold.
It was like 50,
but it was a different kind of 50.
It wasn't like la 50 is nothing january
when we're wearing shorts in january out
here all the time.
But a grown man,
I really should never wear shorts.
Look at my legs,
bitch.
So my legs all sexy and and shit.
When I get gray hair on my legs,
that's when you stopped seeing him in
shorts or you'll see me in shorts with
shaved legs.
SeemeD like you fucking faggot.
The might just remind your legs.
Shaved them.
no,
I'm not gonna die.
I know dudes who do their facial hair.
Facial hair.
But I don't.
I don't do that.
I'm going to shave.
I shaved my balls.
I don't dye my ball here so I'm not
going to die my leg here either.
Right?
It can't be dying to your leg.
Hair.
That's just fucking faggot tree line in
a bathtub with some fucking black gang.
Trying to pretend you're not dying.
You're dying.
You don't die.
You fucking leg hair.
That's hilarious.
And have you ever seen like an old dude
who's hair is dyed?
They have like a reddish tint to the
hair dye.
Looks kind of brown instead of a blonde
base.
Could you imagine if you have it on your
legs and your legs looked like sasquatch
legs?
Ginger,
ginger,
sasquatch?
Who is red band?
What does he do?
Red band is the guy who,
if you ever saw the carlos when see a
video,
you've seen his work,
have you seen the jew clam video?
You've seen his work and if you haven't,
you really need to check that out.
Google jus clam and look away tHe um,
he's.
He does all the videos for um,
for me,
for my website and for,
you know,
we just,
it's like one of the things we do when
we,
uh,
we go on these um,
these shows and we traveled all these
different towns.
One of the things we do is we,
a lot of funny shit happens and we film
it and brian takes all that funny ship
has to watch nine hours of bullshit to
get 10 minutes of awesome this and so 10
minutes have fun and with the right
music and the right editing and he just
makes these cool ass videos.
I just heard some directors
we're talking about shot this movie with
julia more than 21 days and the editing
to five months,
they thought it would take said 10 or 12
weeks.
He goes,
I'll be finishing five to seven to five
months because that's so much longer to
make a joke.
Funny.
You can make a joke.
Not funny.
Oh,
you do whatever you want with editing.
I can'T even imagine.
Should I hate dealing with.
Is this just the music?
Because I make my videos around music,
but then if I pick a song that will get
me banned off youtube and off all these
websites,
then fox and then you have to like try
to do with your own music or make your
own kind of shit.
That's.
And then you lose the creativity part.
You're working with bullshit instead of
working with led zeppelin.
You know,
it's,
I hate it.
I know.
It's like one of martin scorsese's best
movies.
good fellows.
Do you remember the scene where um,
uh,
where it was all falling apart for a,
what's his face or tell them that he was
driving in the car and look at the music
was so important to,
to all that shit immediately.
It's all that rolling stone shit,
you know?
I mean,
it was like you.
That was that
when he,
when he put in,
when he's,
when he's picking up his mail or
whatever,
or the newspaper and they have a,
we did it my way by my vicious and
whatever,
but he was like,
that's a reason he just,
he's not using the sinatra version.
He's on purpose.
He wants the fucking that version of it,
this bastardized version of the mafia
they're trying to show.
It's like,
yes,
it's important.
Yeah.
So music is so important to a good
movie.
All those.
That's one of the great things about
like scorsese tarantino.
Yeah.
Francis ford coppola.
They know how to pick the right fucking
music.
You know,
the great guys,
they know how to really jazz it up.
Right.
And all those good.
The bad,
the ugly.
This world surgery alone,
it always use of more pony or whatever
his name was.
The good,
the bad and the ugly.
I wish I knew had a dj like remix and
stuff like that.
Like because you watched,
it seems like it's so much fun and then
you make your own music and that's,
you know,
in a way,
in a way.
Yeah.
And I just wish I could do that.
You what's weird that a guy gets through
and is huge.
Like there's that guy,
I think his name was t esto.
He's a gigantic dj and these people were
telling me this dude was telling me that
he went to a [inaudible] concert on new
years and it was like this big thing.
I think he did it in south America and
he said it was insane.
It was really crazy more and they're all
in accessing other craziness.
Hundred thousand people on ecstasy and
this guy is janet and this guy gets.
Apparently he liked this multimillion
selling dj guy.
I don't know where they make their
money.
I guess they make their money on
personal appearances.
Just sounds so good.
Whatever excess nightclubs in it makes
it sound like,
oh yeah,
I get it,
but if they're good man,
ecstasy,
I only did it once,
but god damn it feel good.
It's just named right.
It was like a kind of feel.
Yeah,
you got it.
It felt so good,
but it scared the shit out of me the
next day.
The next data.
I never got rid of those.
I might've had shitty ecstasy.
I might have to get me some good extra
step and see what happens,
but it might be my biochemical.
I think it's more of a,
you know,
possible djs produced music,
but they produced music that's like
other people's music that they're like
piecing it together and making it their
own but is an art to it for sure.
You know,
sometimes the people that make the music
don't see it as well as someone who's
listening to the music,
you know,
I,
I know that sounds crazy,
but it's possible that a dj could take a
song that wasn't really that good and
make pretty fucking dope.
And that's possiblE.
Sometimes remixes are better than the
original songs,
you know,
most of the time it is like,
like if you go to a party band or what's
that other dude's a girl talk.
If you go download some of their music,
they take some really good songs.
But mainly listen to a mixed up and
stuff like that.
I actually like that better.
Well,
that's what everybody says about like
quintin tarantino,
right?
That his themes are all stories from
like other movies and it.
But he makes them fucking bad ass.
You know?
That's an interesting little fine line.
Now kick paris seven,
eight,
nine one.
We're having a fight in here.
This dude is telling someone to kick
somebody off.
Oh,
paris.
because paris keeps on saying,
hey,
soup mcculloch joe you want to do is
suck my cock ribbons together.
How much money do you have fellow?
You think that's the real?
Is paris hilton to do it?
Yes.
I want to ban the sender.
Cool.
Bam.
Sorry bitch.
Nobody's getting their cock sucked now.
I was really.
What I was going to do is suck.
Everybody's cocked.
That was listening,
but you had to go and fuck it up.
So.
And I didn't know joey diaz was here.
Oh,
that's already going deep nowadays are
just going deep.
Remember the old red?
That would smoke half a hit and then
like in a car accident on that way
we're getting to hogwan stage.
You got barbecued in vegas.
How?
How'd you get to vegas?
Cool.
You kept going.
We had a joint and usually does this.
The way it works when to do comedy.
One hit.
This should be fun.
It'll be fun to get loose two heads.
So like,
ooh,
you're trusting,
trusting the universe and you're
trusting your state of mind.
We had four heads.
We were.
We were fucking blitzkrieg.
Pop him on more.
The worst is when I was so stoned like
that.
My first week out here.
You invited me to go see you at fear
factor set.
Oh,
that's right.
He gave me these,
these,
these are like,
hey Ohio boy brian,
come here.
You want this out?
Lollipop.
I'm like all sure.
And so I take it and then like 10
minutes later is like,
you feel anything yet?
And I'm like,
no,
let's take another one.
So I took the second one.
Yes.
we take two and in joe's like,
well,
here is hanging out with all the
directors and producers in this trailer.
I got to go now and then it starts
tripping and I'm like,
they're like,
oh no,
they're going.
And they're like,
like he was so,
so yeah,
it was holding
was I called you old ablo for like three
months.
That's how much I hated fear factor.
I hated fear factor so much that I,
I had to do it,
that I would get barbecued.
I would get so fucking hot.
I would take these crazy,
uh,
beyond bomb that was the name of the
company that would make them lollipops
or to eat one of those.
Before I would do fear factor,
I'd be blitzkrieg to the point where I
could remember what I was talking to
about 10 seconds ago and that's how I
would do the show.
Made it so much more interesting.
It's fun to watch fear factor now
knowing that though,
because like all the episodes you can
tell your eyes are all glazed over.
He was lIke,
oh my god,
they're the.
The producers knew it and liked that
fact that I did it because it made me
more relaxed and uh,
there were so many agro douche bags and
then show producers there must work with
so many,
so many.
And if you want to get through she can
make a lot of miserable.
There was most of the people that did
that show were really cool.
They were there to have fun trying to
win some money.
Holy shit.
I'm on tv.
You know,
there was a few like stars.
Yeah.
They got douchey.
Well not only have they got aggressive,
you know,
there was,
there was some contestants that will
like real aggressive,
you know,
and that was annoying because they were
all hyped up trying to win this fucking
show and they would start shit with me.
You know,
they're at home in jersey practicing and
joe rogan shit.
There's one more suited him,
so I don't really say it,
but they're already wrapped up by the
time they get there.
I'm like,
hey man,
relax.
I'm here to help you.
So the weed helps with that.
The weed helps.
Nothing.
Nothing helps you deal with aggression
better than we'd hoped for.
Gifts.
Sometimes the people that watCh it.
Oh,
right there.
So I'm very nice.
Was that the vegas show?
Last may says a dune.
Dune,
john d,
you and jan.
I know we were talking about.
Yeah,
we're talking about saturday night,
friday night the,
um,
we do the house of blues and vegas all
the time.
We also do the palms and uh,
I'm going to be doing that like every
couple months we're going to do that.
The palms more?
Yeah.
Why later?
But yeah,
just more regular.
More of a club.
Yeah,
I think so too.
And if it's similar,
the other stuff and it's set up that
way.
Yeah.
It's the only thing I don't like about
the poems is that the stage lighting,
it's not the best.
The house of blues is all like really
lit up well,
but they might have fixed that.
I know that's not a big fix.
Just a spotlight,
but yeah.
So either way we're going to be in vegas
a lot.
Talk about mma.
Joe.
Fuck mark gaining.
Oh that's john copenhagen.
I want,
if that's the real john copenhagen,
that's the war machine would have.
Is that the real market and ah,
that's cool.
Real john copenhagen.
The war machine wouldn't have a fucking
little tweety bird next to him.
What does that with those tweety birds?
A Yellow in the picture because they
just joined or there a lot of ufc guys
warm.
Shane's got a pIcture of him looking all
bought off on it.
The palms has the naked girl pick
onstage.
Yes.
That is.
Yeah,
exactly.
When you're on stage of the palms,
right to your left.
There's a naked picture.
There's a picture of a girl showing her
pussy with the new workplace.
Yeah.
She's got her tits,
her out and she's like showing a little
bit of pubic hair.
Red onstage and.
Oh,
because the playboy and the playboy
comedy club.
Yeah.
It's very strange man.
But I think we're going to do that.
I didn't want to do that much more to
the next one.
We're doing that in february.
Is there any female comics that you know
of that show their pussy all the time?
Like,
like joy chosen?
Any?
No,
that'd be awesome.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
God's like,
oh Yeah.
There's nothing funny about a girl show
and her pussy dude pulls his dick out.
Well,
what?
That's funny.
Like,
look,
I'm fingering myself with my cell phone
or what happened when you were young?
What happened?
Sarah silverman.
sarah silverman.
But she wouldn't be fun if she showed
her pussy.
She's funny.
She talks about it,
but if she showed it she killed.
I did that k rock thing with her last
year.
There was like a.
I'm like,
well,
there's sOme k rock comedy use.
alaris crushed.
God damn.
She crushed it.
She's funny man to do,
to do that.
And I was walking to.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
That guy's a really good one,
right?
I've always seen that starbucks.
He's always with his kid.
He's like being dad.
Mr dad and stuff with the kids family.
He.
Oh,
he always surprises me with where he
goes with his writing.
I really like his writing,
you know,
his,
um,
his stuff.
He'll go someplace and he'll take a
premise that like you would think like
maybe you would like think about like
maybe I'll talk about this on stage and
then go ask funny enough,
but he makes it fun to actually make the
Joke out of it.
yeah.
He beat it down and conforms it and
makes it funny with his writinG.
He always takes shit to a place.
I'm always surprised.
come to seattle.
I'm going to come to seattle
motherfucker eventually.
Is it better to change the.
I don't know.
I've not heard good again,
but this is a stupid way to,
to see this because these hashtags
things.
ThIs was stupid.
Well,
because it keeps growing and they can't
fucking read it.
At least when you go to actual twitter,
it doesn't do that.
Oh,
we have to go to actual twitter.
You can actually sit there and stop it.
I'm not looking at hashtags.
I'm just looking at that.
Um,
that app thing.
Now I'm going to just look at that.
Now.
Can we do that?
What happened with dreams thinking if
that's how he's doing it.
I think eastern's thinking if there's
alternative people that do the hashtag,
theY don't show up as a trending topic.
Yeah.
Here's a good question.
Salvia.
Have you ever done it?
Brian's done.
Salvia.
You have videos on.
Did have a video already?
I did it once.
Did you put a video up?
If you do that?
Brian does.
Was alex
super cool.
It just of tripping out.
You're on top of a house is looking at
people's lawns or something like that.
Bags on my on my childhood long could
feel that reality here and the other
reality it went like this and I've been
right here at the real reality here and
I was trying to like not make them
overlap because I'll never come back.
I was like,
no,
I'm not there.
It's not credible.
I thought my face became carpet and then
it melted and tore off and then I went
down a water slide and then I was like,
are you talking about.
You're talking about my face.
How crazy is that?
That's legal.
Salvia is illegal in some places is it's
actually turning illegal now a couple of
places.
FlorIda.
Yeah,
but there's 50 states,
lord.
I'm going to make it illegal now.
Pretty fast though.
I think they just did seven states
recently or something like that.
Damn,
this,
the mark gaydon,
whoever you are.
Gonna block.
You see?
Yeah.
You talked too much.
So Mark Hayden?
I don't think so.
It's a fake one.
Now.
What's real?
It's real marketing.
It's real.
wow.
Just like the cheaters is woman
canadian.
Alicia says,
were they all on lollipops also the
contestants?
No,
I've got the contestants high on meth
because you want to have a good show.
You want to have a good motIvated group
of people out there trying to compete.
So they said it was common knowledge
that the set supplied.
No,
I'm making.
Hey,
have you ever seen this?
No one was on any drugs.
Ladies and gentlemen,
they were british style book for years
and uh,
we gave him a diet coke
can,
you can have a water if you wanted that
too.
Or you could have a regular coke if you
don't give a fuck.
But no,
there was no.
Now the contestants who weren't on
drugs,
it was just me.
I was,
I'm a little bit Of weed to try to get
through the day
you ever.
That puts you with gray pubic hair yet
in real life.
How not in real life have you?
No,
really not yet,
but one day that's all we're going to be
seeing.
One day you're going to be like,
why'd you start shaving your pussy?
Shut up.
I wAnt to talk about that green or gray
10.
Yeah.
It's going to always look dusty.
Oh no.
Something on it is that you're going to
be able to see the ingrown hair
of the knees and elbows.
What other mma rules we like to see on
it?
I don't know.
You know,
I think that should be up to a vote
with.
They should allow rural new knees on the
ground,
stuff like that.
I think in a certain there's a certain
part about knees on the ground and kicks
or the cage.
You can't get away from them In certain
places so that it becomes where you get
trapped up against the cage.
Dudes are going to take damage that theY
wouldn't normally take.
Whereas like if they did it in a ring,
the thing about the ring is you could
slide out of that bitch,
you can get your head under it and just
avoid the kicker could instead of having
to stop right on.
Yeah,
you can't get trapped there.
I mean you kind of get trapped in the
turn buckle,
but not the same.
It's,
there's openings all over the place.
What about having a warning tracker on
the cage and you can't kick somebody in
the head on the ground inside that
warren truck.
That's a good idea to go baseball
looking.
You just thought it.
That's a real good idea right there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the warning track around the knees on
the ground are not effective and so what
you do is you grab a guy,
get him in a fucking hold and you pull
them into the middle of the nail on the
head niamh on the ground maybe.
Yeah,
that would.
That's actually a smart move.
That would make it really interesting.
More strategies.
People trying to go to that warning
track.
I think that people will be excited
about that too.
You know,
like the nea,
the nea,
and you're near the uh,
the knee area in the middle.
It's like,
oh shit,
just in the middle.
What's it going to do?
We can't go anywhere.
It's going to be in the.
Yeah.
And people would talk shit.
Well,
he was real smart and stayed away from
the need area.
I was like,
fuck them up in that knee if you're
scared my strength show.
Well he didn't want to bang with me.
They didn't want to with me.
Oh,
fucking shut.
He wanted to fight.
Didn't want to do,
do,
do.
This guy says in the past broadcast with
ufc,
with guest announcers you find that
limits your broadcasting or messes with
chemistry now?
No.
You know,
those guys were nice guys.
I did it once with craig hummer and once
with a vascular surgeon.
They're both nice guys.
Very professional,
you know,
but go burst my,
he's a good buddy.
We're friends.
We're real good friends.
So I liked having him around.
It's fun and I think he's excellent.
what he does.
That shit's very hard.
That I received bill hicks live be
frederick 30.
Yeah,
some of a couple of times I saw him in
la when he was just like,
just starting to be known.
It was fun.
I saw him clear room.
I saw him bomb.
He went up after this,
uh,
this really hacky guy and the guy was
doing all these impressions of different
cartoon characters,
smoking weed and it was just,
he's a nice guy,
but it was just really hacky stuff when
the audience was eating it up and hicks
went on afterwards with all this George
Bush war,
John Davidson,
she coming out of oprah winfrey's asks
when oprah winfrey's all.
No,
it wasn't an oprah winfrey who was a,
he would,
he would do it with a bunch of different
people.
But anyway,
he has these crazy fucking bits and
social commentary and the audit is
getting up in giant chunks.
They were getting up like 10,
15 people at the time.
They left,
they abandoned him and he was just
eating it onstage onstage,
but we were loving it.
It was like me and maybe like seven or
eight other comics was bombing better
than I'd ever seen anybody bomb.
He was bombing like a Champion,
like you didn't give a fuck.
He's taking a shit,
right?
He's doing this bit where I said I don't
remember who the.
He did one.
sometimes you have to do it with,
with oprah winfrey.
I don't think that was over this time,
but it was like that,
that uh,
she shits out John davidson,
so I forget how it goes.
But it was a really funny.
John davidson was the host of that
incredible.
Yeah.
What's that?
Maybe it was the devil fuck John
Davidson.
So anyway,
she's in the middle.
He's in the middle of squattinG down on
stage,
just making these moaning noises that
he's taking a shit and he's doing it for
like a minute.
Like he's like,
yeah,
that usually clears her own and then it
goes back to it and he did it like
without any,
there was no feeling that he was self
conscious.
It waS like a feeling like,
oh yeah,
and fuck it.
It wasn't like,
holy shit,
I'm bombing.
It was like he was making fun of it and
it was,
it was awesome.
It was,
it was really,
really interesting to watch.
It was like the best I'd ever seen
anybody bomb,
but we,
like I said,
we laughed our asses off and I seen him
kill too.
I saw him kill a couple of times out of
the common connection with all his.
A jimi hendrix is jimi hendrix.
When debbie gibson was famous,
jimmy hendrix running into debbie gibson
at the mall.
So yeah,
it was really loud and it was funny
stuff.
He was a lot like,
I'm like,
sam kennison a lot.
Why kinison like you could tell like
that they,
they work together,
you know,
and dudes work together as much as we
try not to.
We pick up a little piece of each
other's styles.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
And it's part of it is like,
I dunno,
it's like we all say powerful,
right?
You know why?
Why?
So why do we all say powerful?
Because my friend larry,
because larry said malaria was the
original powerful.
So you got to give credit to the
originaL powerful.
But everybody says powerful.
It's like it's out there.
It's nobody's now.
No.
One second.
They're it.
Exactly.
Rad is a perfect example or anything
like that.
There's like something thAt's hot.
It just becomes a part of the
vernacular.
Huge,
huge,
all that shit to,
to,
to niche and when that happens.
But that's the original powerfuls larry.
But anyway,
my point is that bill hicks and
kennison,
uh,
I don't know which came first.
The chicken or the egg.
I don't know who was influencing hill.
I know kennison was the godfather common
in houston.
He was the guy that made everybody want
to do comedy.
He was the guy that was the,
the leader of the outlaws.
And hicks was clearly like his
underlying.
But if you look at like the writing,
like hicks's writing are so much
different,
you know,
there were so different,
when they,
they both developed into their own
thing.
You know,
hicks always had to like say something,
whereas kinison was just fucking,
we're here for fun.
We're here to party.
We're here for chaos.
Go with
the kennedy center.
Anywhere you've got to take.
Yeah,
I definitely,
he'd have to say I did it with jokes.
Like I think that life keeps fucking you
in the ass.
Oh.
It was like,
wow,
you can't say better or you really felt
about life.
Can't say better.
That was an awesome one and the one on
the starving children in those
commercials.
Come on.
That's one of the greatest comedy bits
in the history of the universe when he's
doing that bit about those kids
starviNg.
I'm like,
well,
what do you want me to feed them?
Why don't you feed them?
You're right fucking now that it's like,
don't feed them.
Settle people like me.
Is that a p seven people that are going
to go there and tell you that we
wouldn't have to come here 5,000
miles with your food.
A few people live.
There's no windshield thoughts.
The tester
come here and let the fucker.
No,
this is that.
He was going to be a thousand years from
now.
Fuck it.
Sand.
We got deserts in America too.
We just don't live it.
I'm an to ask
when you go.
God damn.
I mean,
when I first saw that,
I was like,
that's the greatest comedy I've ever
seen ever.
this is completely not caring,
just didn't give a fuck and there was no
one like it because I grew up in like
when I first heard kinison,
I was living in the really conservative
boston,
really religious.
Everyone waS either catholic or jewish.
Very conservative,
lot of angry people,
but also very conservative.
You never heard shit like that.
Nothing.
Never heard.
People have the balls to talk like that.
Even when your friends are around,
you're all by yourselves.
You don't have the balls to talk that
crazy.
So to hear someone like that and you're
like,
whoa.
He changed comedy.
He's one of those guys that came on and
change comedy.
There was nobody like that beforehand.
He was a total original,
a young comedian,
special.
When you See
it was on it,
a couple other guys,
but nelson or whatever his name was and
it was like either you've seen him come
on and you're like,
oh,
it's all going to be that from now on.
It's all way anymore.
Yeah,
they were fine.
They were all good,
but he was just so raw,
so much energy,
so much power and what he was saying
made so much.
there's also real.
Yeah.
It wasn't like this is.
That was the same one with bob nelson.
Bob nelson,
yeah.
Let me put balloons in here.
it's my impression of a football player
and he runs up and it's like,
all right,
that's thing you did,
but you don't.
Yeah,
it's not.
It wasn't as good.
Wouldn't do in cancer.
And did that joke about jesus,
you think jesus is coming back?
I think the last words we ever heard
from jesus or
oh,
that whole screaming style,
that powerful style.
I mean that's my favorite kind of
comedy.
like joey diaz when he's mad,
that is fucking screaming at you when
he's getting fucking crazy fuckers
fuckers kill
osama bin.
Ladin killed George Bush.
I'll fucking.
I'll.
She'll call me brian.
$5.
Kill them all.
I liked them.
I liked them all.
Feed retarded shit too,
but I'm like,
that's a beautiful thing about comedy is
you can't tell someone how to do comedy,
right?
Nobody can do it correctly.
Just everybody's got their own way.
Comedy is just a nutty fucking art forum
now.
Everybody's got a different way of doing
it in every way works.
You know,
like if mitch hedberg was trying to do
is act like kinison,
that'll be crazy.
But if kennedy was trying to do is.
I've got mitch heDberg,
like what?
I wonder if there's any footage of old
old bitch hedberg right when I started
doing open mics and I was trying to do
like a little boy from comedy developed.
It will be really interesting to see how
well have you seen the um,
larry the cable guy videos.
that's incredible.
Dan whitney that's got larry the cable
guy is the most successful standup
comedian and the history of the world.
No one's even close as far as live gate
sales.
He sells out like football arena,
football arena.
It was like 50,000
people.
Josh wolfe opens for him.
They get on a giant stage and a fucking
football arena.
Dude,
that's crazy.
He had pictures of it on his phone.
He was showing him the pictures.
He was like,
look man,
this is the audience.
And you look at it,
y'all,
what the fuck?
That's like a world you're doIng it for
like you're doing as a country.
How do you connect with all those
fucking peanuts?
Color jokes?
Slowly.
I don't know,
man.
Do you think you could connect with all
those people?
No.
I bet you that with our full charismatic
motherfucker,
they would have to really like you to.
To connect with all those beautiful
facial expressions are so far back.
It's true because the only thing is that
they would have to have some big ass
screen.
I'm sure they'll have a.
But football arenas are primarily their
outdoor things right there.
There was never covered,
covered.
Sometimes heated.
Sometimes there's just not the time.
Sometimes we needed up there.
If they're indoors in minneapolis,
the metro community,
it's like 30 below zero and I was like,
I have outside of green bay,
have outside 30 below zero people go to
the game.
Never cancel football games.
Football games or a mother fuckers.
Man,
when you see those have no shirt on.
He ended up nuts.
Mad.
There's something cool about that.
There's something,
if you want to talk about a sport that
really does represent America,
that represents America,
that's a crazy ass fucking sport.
They will play even if it's pouring
rain.
Oh,
ran out of shit.
So in some countries they have to deal
with inclement weather so much.
Some places have to deal with some
weight went on.
Nothing.
In California baseball it's like,
looks like it's 73 degrees.
It's not incredible.
I could say one or two.
It will be harder to not even hitting
each other with anything.
You know?
Those guys are snowed in and they're
running into each other full clip and
the fucking freezing cold you remember?
can you remember like when you were a
little kid,
you fall.
When it was cold out,
it would hurt so much more.
Well,
catching a football to kogan somebody's
website and go,
oh fuck.
It hurts so bad.
I mean,
how cold?
How much does it hurt when you get
clipped by a fucking gigantic through
mine though.
That must be so painful.
Do you think we've reached the end of
this program?
Was it something.
This is about the end.
We've determined that at two hours in we
usually start getting boring shit.
And ari,
ari shapiro got the munchies,
all of my,
um,
we didn't take that many questions,
but hopefully we were entertaining to
bitches.
The questions helped us go onto yes.
Yes,
definitely.
Well,
if it wasn't for you guys,
we couldn't have done this obviously.
What did we do?
We just talked.
They'll take a call to deal with for a
while and they'll go off until they are
ready for another color,
you know,
they'll just keep going.
well,
we've been looking for something like
this for a long time.
We've been looking for something like
this,
like to do some sort of a radio show and
I've talked about it like,
hey,
maybe we could all do like death squad
radio or something like that.
But really what I realized is that the
best way to do it is to do it like this,
do it on the internet and we'll have
this thing evolve.
Turn this room into like a real like
setup where you can sit down and watch
her sexual studio.
we're going to have laptop set up so
that we can play videos like you know,
like hey,
there's a,
you know,
some crazy new fucking animal attack
video you so that when we do play it,
but it was just plug it in and then
next week we're going to have it at a
different.
Next week Is when we're going to have
all that,
all that stuff.
Like video on video.
We could have like three people talking
at once.
We're just,
he's going to have is internet and done.
It's done.
I just have to change the router next
week so we'll have a bunch of fun shit.
Yeah.
Well we're gonna do is.
We're going to keep doing this every
week and we're gonna.
I'm like,
it's gonna.
It's gonna expand and eventually I think
eventually the internet is gonna make
its way into your car.
That's what I think is going to happen.
I think the internet would podcasts and
stuff like that.
Like we aren't making mp3s of this.
We should have.
Maybe we can.
Can we make it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
we'll start making mp3s and put it up as
podcast because there was nothing about
this,
what you needed to see us.
So we're going to do a show like this
and then,
um,
we're gonna.
We're Just gonna do a lot more internet
stuff.
really.
The,
what'S really good about any sort of a
television show is the money a and the
fact that people now come out to see
your standup,
which is what we're always trying to
work on.
You know,
I mean,
if you've never seen ari,
ari is fucking hilarious.
There's a lot of dudes that are out
there that are headline and these big
clubs that in my opinion,
they're,
they're not as developed as,
as,
they're not as funny as rs,
but ari doesn't have that many credits.
So it's hard for just clubs to book him.
and then they assume that people are
going
to come out and see him.
You know,
people come out and see somebody because
they know that guy from a movie or from
a television show or whatever.
But ours are filthy pig and he goes on
stage and these auditions and uh,
they say whatever you do don't talk
about rape.
So what does already do?
You just minute rapists,
which is a hilarious bit.
But you know,
like the reason why some dudes are funny
is also the reason why people don't find
out that some dudes are funny.
We have a guy that we know that's
probably one of the funniest guys ever.
This got brian holtzman and no one knows
who brian halterman has because he's so
crazy and he should have,
it should have,
he should have hit big.
He was the guy that,
he was so crazy.
We would always go into the back of the
room and watch him when he was real
hatred.
Yeah.
And get so angry and nutty.
And every now and then they break
character just.
And a nice guy to be around to when he
was hanging around at the club was
always friendly and know.
And I would love to see a reality show
at brody stevens and him and they lived
together.
Why?
Brody was too sensitive.
He'd get mad,
but when.
That'd be great.
No.
Brody,
stevens and bret ernst?
No,
no.
Holtzman and brody stevens together.
The following convenience would be
worthwhile for like a show.
Like if you look at like,
like the kardashians.
Real real.
I think it would be.
Could get help fucked up some more.
What's the appeal of Cuba number?
The kardashians.
Just that she's got a fat ass.
That's It.
Yeah.
They're dumb,
but a lot of people are dumb too.
They don't mind.
We'll sort of,
you know,
they have some money.
Not,
not like paris hilton money with lots of
people go to asos.
Yeah,
but you just got to put one on tv.
People become famous just because their
ass and veto guerra chick.
I know who she is.
She probably doesn't need a hawaiian.
I know she is.
Why?
Because of harassed.
I don't even know what her voice sounds
like.
I know her face looks like joey diaz,
but she's.
But she's only doing what she's doing,
but they'll take someone like what's her
name?
Okay.
You're,
you're a tv star now.
Jennifer lopez.
How about that?
Famous because of ras.
Not really famous because her talent but
recognized because of her ass.
That's like one celebrity with everybody
talk.
If you talk about Jennifer Lopez,
you talk about or ask if there's a lot
of celebrities that have great assets
and our feet,
our feet are hot.
Fucking weirdo tablets in feet.
That's very strange.
Very strange thing.
but uh,
anyway,
we're always trying to do something fun
where we could all do it together and
just hang out and shoot the shit because
we have these conversations sometimes
and we say,
man,
you know,
this is way more fun than like,
like a radio show.
Why don't we do our own thing like this?
Just figuring out how to get it made as
always.
The bitch.
That's always the hard part.
But this is easy.
You know,
now that there's something like this,
we don't have to figure out shit,
so we'll do this.
I think it's a good creative outlet.
Like we have to go over what we said
today,
but there was some funny shit that could
have been bits.
No,
because we do have a three 63,
60 of the whole room,
multiple cameras face each other and a
couple of cameras.
Cameras.
Yeah,
I may have it next week.
We have it set up so you can choose
which camera you want.
So it's multiple cameras.
Can we have it?
So they set up the choose which cameras
but everyone comes off one sound feed.
Oh,
okay.
Good.
Oh,
that's awesome.
All right,
well that's what we're going to do.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm a four square box and uh,
just going to do more of this shit.
Let you guys know what the fuck is going
down this sunday night.
Ari and I are at the 9:30
club in Washington dc and it's always
old stomping grounds.
So if there's any new hookers out there
with an itchy mouth
that elidel nothing to do with my old
stomping grounds.
Willard Scratched topic.
He's been saying he really would like a
blow to the trade show in dc.
It's the way we get our new president,
barack obama.
And on That note,
ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much for tuning into our
little youtube or you choose me,
ustream ustream show and we'll see you
next week.
and,
um,
eventually we'll have a regular time
that we try to adhere to every week and
it might move around a little bit,
but for the most part it will be like
around now,
like wednesday afternoon,
possibly tuesday stuff out.
If you get started more on time,
people get used like at three,
it'll be all right.